this is Jocko podcast number 236 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening when I went
through basic SEAL training there were
two people recognized with an award at
the end of training the first award was
for the honor man and the honor man is
the guy in the class I think it's for
the best sort of overall performance
which is mostly physical running
swimming obstacle course pull-ups
sit-ups or whatever whatever other
physical events you do life-saving and
not tying in buddy breathing and pool
competency and you kind of have to just
do good at everything and not just good
you have to do really good and
everything it seems like the honor man
is gonna be one of those people who did
some kind of athletics and in high
school maybe even college in my class
the honor man was a complete badass his
name was Keith Chimaera total stud he
and I don't remember everything about
buds but I remember that he won just
about everything although there was one
other guy that was always right there
with him but somehow keith must have
edged him out enough times to become the
honor man I never was close enough to
the front of the pack to knew to know
which of those two guys want but
obviously it must have been Keith
because he was just pretty much savage
at everything and even after SEAL
training he he pushed himself hard tried
to maintain that edge and after his
first tour at a team he went back to
Budds to be an instructor and on January
10th 1997 keith was practicing breath
holds
during an evolution with the students in
the dive tower and the other instructors
were well they were working with the
students and they were running the
evolution and they weren't tracking
Keith who was down at the bottom of the
50-foot tower holding his breath and at
some point at some point he passed out
and because he was just sitting down
there almost in a meditative way no one
really noticed that he had passed out he
took on water by the time the other
instructors recognized what had happened
he was unconscious and he never he never
regained consciousness and he ended up
dying the next day January 11th 1997 a
better man than me the other person the
other award that gets given out at the
end of buds is called the fire in the
gut award and I I don't know if there's
some kind of official definition for
this award but it seems like the award
was given to the individual that had to
dig the deepest to get through the
training and who in doing so also
inspired and motivated the rest of the
class and in my class cost 177 that was
another badass man
a guy by the name of Jeff Higgs and his
journey to buds to basic SEAL training
and through basic SEAL training is a
pretty incredible story and because of
that you know we're we're brothers but
we're brothers not only because we went
to buds together not only because we
served at SEAL team one together but
also through jiu-jitsu I'm I'm I'm
pretty sure we both started the
jiu-jitsu journey the same exact day and
we are connected through our jiu-jitsu
lineage because Jeff Higgs eventually
got his black belt he gave the black
belt - Dean Lister Dean Lister gave the
black belt to me
and I guess we should include that
there's also a connected lineage here to
echo Charles who then received his black
belt from me and it's been a while but
it's an honor to have Jeff here with me
today to share his experiences his
knowledge his outlook and his lessons
learned in life Jeffrey hey thanks for
having me thanks for coming all man
always good always good to see you to
hear you I heard you at some pretty I
heard your voice at some pretty
traumatic times and in my life so it's
always good to to sit down with you
obviously we trained a ton but let's
start at the beginning but started young
Jeff Higgs where were you born I was
born in Rams you're in North Carolina
it's a town like almost smack-dab in the
middle of the state in rural area and
what was uh what was the situation there
no like what was your mom and dad doing
there what was scenario
at the time my parents were separated so
I was you know I was you know my mom had
me there and moved back to New York when
I was about three so was she was she a
New Yorker originally no my mom's from
that that town and where was your dad
from my dad was born in the Bronx grew
up in Harlem and so then so they had
they moved down there together or where
they already split up and she took you
down yeah they were split up and I
wasn't born yet so I was born down there
the rest of my family was born in in New
York and then and then you moved back to
New York at what age three my mom moved
back so at this point I hadn't really
met my father and my mom moves back to
New York and then it was a kind of a
whole family issue thing that I wouldn't
want to get into publicly but my dad got
custody of me and ended up growing there
with my father and going to my mother's
back and forth on weekends mm-hmm
and then whereabouts in New York where
you live in so I grew up on Staten
Island in a place called West Brighton
projects so that's where I lived with my
father and my mom lived in another
project called Park Hill projects so a
lot of people are familiar with that
Stapleton Park a hill all right next to
each other like the wu-tang clan is from
Stapleton from from West Brighton Mark
mahomes area there was like the force
MDS there was some people who had to
come out of that area that had gotten
Fame and then like I remember when I was
a kid and I would take the train down to
the city and we would go by you know I'm
coming down from New England from
Connecticut you know whereas in the
sticks you know I grew up on a dirt road
and so we'd be on the train me and my
buddies and you'd be going through the
projects for it's probably it seemed
like about maybe 20 minutes of riding
the train where it's just a building
building bill
building you can tell that they're in
rough shape and you know I would always
be sitting there on this train you know
coming in from a really rural area and
looking in there thinking that looks
rough
yeah the old projects very much the same
in the northeast area you know there are
rough areas so what did your dad do for
a living
my dad worked with like housing so he
didn't know I have too much education
but um you know he did what he could
he worked in the housing department so
he worked in the flight for the projects
for the city like you know what I
remember like as a kid he would take me
into these uh big boiler rooms like we'd
go down underneath the building and you
know for it's winter in New York you
have these boilers that heat the
buildings and the boilers are huge you
know you can see the fire in there and
you'd show me how to you know show me
the gauges and all that and how to
operate it's pretty cool and and you
what I know you have at least a sister
what else do you have for siblings I
have three older brothers and two older
sisters so I'm the youngest the youngest
yes
we're all that were all of you
co-located in the same house with your
dad yes you know there are all kinds of
situations going on there so I'm not
really gonna divulge of my family is to
writing a book or so yeah but but so it
was pretty much some of the kids that
were around some of the time year around
sounds like you said weekends with your
mom but the rest of time with your dad
yeah and for the most part my my
brothers and sisters we were with my
father okay and I'd visit my mom on the
weekends and then what were you doing
like what were your interests what was
going to school like okay as a kid I was
very thin and I had like an an incident
happened like I guess like in second
grade or so I got really sick like I got
sick in front of a bunch of people
in school and I was just really
embarrassed by it and I didn't want to
get sick again so I stopped eating a lot
so I was really thin but besides that
and that and that went on for a long
time I would so much so what grade was
that
that's like second grade so you got you
mean when you say you got sick you mean
you threw up in front of a bunch of
people yeah we were doing like this play
like The Lion the Witch and the Wardrobe
so I've got and I was just I told the
teacher I'm like I do not feel good and
she just let me sat sit there and then I
was like they put out a bucket in front
of me this is New York in like the late
seventies really and then it came out
just started you know going at it right
there and everyone in the class just
scattered and they're like just like
point that mean and it was just like is
it I couldn't do anything you know it's
like I had no control and the body was
just doing what I was doing and I was uh
I just kind of toned down my eating and
I would eat like just a piece of bread
in the day but I mean besides that I was
uh you know really bookish read a lot of
comic books encyclopedias I was just
reading all the time and pretty much
like pretty much a nerd you know I would
walk around and that was that's why I
was a target in that kind of
neighborhood you're definitely gonna be
a target mm-hmm you know I used to have
I used to carry this book in my pocket
called the golden guide Gotham guide
golden guide you can still find him and
I even bought the book because you know
just for a nostalgia sake but it's a
little book of spiders of North America
so that you know peevish decorum
this is spider-man because I would I
would come up you know I'm like this
little kid like oh that's electrode Ekta
smacked hands and like saying all these
species names of these arachnids
different types of arthropods and people
were like this kid and I would collect
spiders and go down and get ants
and putting the web it was like pretty
twisted yes looking back on it look but
that's got to completely isolate you
from like other kids especially in the
projects yeah it's kind of weird
especially like my dad said I was creepy
you you don't do you think that like
when you were sick in front of all those
people when you kind of got called out
it's funny cuz we're sitting here
laughing about that but that kind of
stuff leaves a mark on kids right yeah
it leaves a mark on kids do you think
that left a mark do you think that's
what made you kind of become more into
books because books couldn't laugh at
you know I was I was into post before
that but I think it made me more
introverted mm-hmm you know because now
the spotlights on but it's not for
something good and everyone's laughing
and pointing and like a lot of people
just really discussed it it was just it
was you know really stands out in my
mind so then what was it seems like you
know you're reading books you're kind of
a nerd well what about like as you get
older as you get into high school I mean
damn you know like I said from me
especially in the 80s you know like
going down to the city in the 80s it was
mayhem down there it was total mayhem
yeah the drug dealers the the pimps the
prostitutes like I remember we used to
go out at night and you'd see like
prostitutes at probably around 10 or 11
o'clock at night and they'd be out on
the streets you know working and then
we'd come back at three or four o'clock
and when we go to see a hardcore show or
whatever we come back later and there'd
be those girls they'd be out there you
know turning tricks they'd be looking
like they'd been turning tricks all
night I mean how does a how does a kid
that's reading about spiders get through
that without getting dragged into it oh
I think one of the main reasons for my
path in life was being the youngest in
my family I could see different mistakes
I'm not even gonna say mistakes but I
just I'll say different choices that
other people made and I'm like
maybe I'll go this way I think when
you're the youngest you may want to look
to be distinctive because you're
everyone's always telling you do this do
this do this and you want to think for
yourself mm-hmm
so I think maybe that's that's a reason
were you getting any guidance from your
older siblings that we're saying hey you
might not want to do this because the
other thing man this is such a negative
way to look at human nature but so often
you see people try and drag other people
down and I mean this was in the SEAL
Teams this is where I know it from in
the SEAL Teams where you know you'd have
somebody that was trying to kind of move
in the right direction the other guys
would kind of drag them back down you
know like they wouldn't want people to
succeed and and that's not a blanket
statement but I'm just saying it happens
and and I could definitely see it
happening within families where you know
one sibling does start starts to do
something well and the other siblings
kind of grab them and drag them back now
but I can also see sibling saying don't
make that mistake go in this direction
did you see either one of those or was
it more just your perception of what to
do and what not to do I would say my
siblings my brother and his sisters have
always been really cool with me you know
I'm kind of like I feel really blessed
in that sense you know they always
steered me in the right direction and
and the weird thing was around the
neighborhood you know I was known as
like little Higgs and my other brother
was a similar age you know we were like
you know that they were like oh you know
look out for those guys so I mean we
would sometimes I'd be walking by the
lobby in my building and the guys the
drug dealers right there I know the guy
he lives up on that floor you know you
just know he sells drugs he does his
thing and hey what's up little head you
just walk right by you know was never
like I never really felt like I wanted
to get involved in that stuff
so I didn't really have too much of an
issue but I could see all these things
going on around and this is like in the
in the 80s in New York City which is
very different than it is now I would
say you know was definitely a rougher
time oh yeah when's the last time you
were back in New York
just this few months ago I see my
brother so I go visit my brother and you
know he still lives in Harlem
so I'll visit him you know pretty much
when I'm coming back from overseas or
some I just stopped over there yeah yeah
New York is a completely and utterly
different place now than it was in the
eighties
nevermind the seventies I wasn't never
went down there in the 70s but in the
eighties for sure what about um you know
one of the things you used to tell us
stories me I mean you and I would sit
down and talk for a long time we were
going through training and you tell me
stories about some of the characters in
the projects there was I know there's a
couple brothers that seem to have they
seem to be they seem to have their own
like world that you kind of brushed up
into sometimes it is it was this like I
mean I remember these stories bad give
us a little hint of those guys what was
their deal so these two brothers Mark
and James they just I don't even know
what started it just they just had it
out for me mostly James and these guys
would every time they would see me you
know they were high on something and
they would make this salad and when I
heard that so that was like I you know I
would start running I'm guessing like
looking back they're seeing this kid
with glasses on looking at a spider book
in the corner of a building and they're
just like Target and you know that's
that's how it started and this I used to
be in the corner just getting taking
punches from these guys in it so it
started with them what you're saying
right yeah and and that's how you'd know
that they were coming for you yeah and
and it was also kind of a signal because
in the projects you know each building
is kind of like its own entity and like
maybe a guy in another building it's
like a signal to that person so you hear
like ooh then way in existence you'd
hear
so weird thing going on so the funny
thing is this is fast-forward a little
bit but you know we are going through
steel trading Jeff you would do that
like it at moments of whatever like mill
moments of chaos where they're trying to
get us to quit all of a sudden you'd
hear so I read just needs to be said
though I was I told that story to
someone and that person just started
saying it over and over and then it's
spread so then everyone was saying it so
I wasn't like you know just randomly and
this is someone started and then it just
spread and then it's like bloods stt to
the teams so uh so when you get to high
school is your attitude changes your
attitude the same through high school
Harry - what happened in high school so
when I was 12 my dad was a football
coach you know I was doing like Pop
Warner football and I was one of the
worst on the team for sure and you know
my dad was always trying to encourage me
you know you got to try different things
so try football try this try that and
you know my dad one day I came home and
he was blowing his nose and when he
pulled the tissue away it was just blood
everywhere
and like you could see like chunks and
stuff like like didn't look right at all
like he knew something was wrong and he
was like I you know I got a bad flu and
we didn't really think anything of it
and then finally you know I guess he
went to the doctor and then we found out
that he had leukemia so that was in
November and it just got progressively
worse so this is 83 late 83 and then he
ended up you know going in the hospital
to get chemotherapy back then was way
more harsh and so you know from like
November to like where he he
died in January 4th and so it was just
only a couple months of this but you
know after school I would come I would
just walk to this hospital that he was
in it was on the way back home from the
school and just watch I just watch my
dad go from someone really big and
strong and just watch him just shrivel
you know going through this treatment so
between the leukemia the chemotherapy
then he got pneumonia from the just
being sitting in the bed and hepatitis
from a blood transfusion you know it's
just a whole bunch of things happen and
then you know he died so you said that
that things changed did that change your
outlook on things did you did you start
to look at the world in a totally
different way now yeah I would say you
know everyone has that that um pivotal
point in their life where like I guess
you can say like innocence is lost like
it's not like you know a fairy tale in
life anymore
you know I basically death was
introduced really quickly you know early
on in my lifes and I just saw it and
that changed me because I became even
more introverted more introverted yeah
so I would have maybe a friend or two at
school but you know I would just be into
my own my own world pretty much and did
that where you where were you living now
I was still in West Brighton projects
visiting my mom back and forth was your
older siblings taking care of you er so
that's where it's a little you know for
my family dicey but essentially at a
stepmom at that point and I was going
between my stepmom and my mom's on the
weekends you know getting involved in
the you know right after your father
passed away and then you're going into
courts and all these during these rooms
with these people doing psychological
evaluation do you want to stay with now
your your your stepmom or your mom and
you
it's just really confusing to me and
just kind of overwhelmed that kind of
like in a sense checked out so yeah it's
what happened so are you - are you still
participating in school like actively
like okay I'm gonna graduate did you
have some kind of plan are you are you
studying at night anything like that I'm
not a one thing about my schoolwork I'm
not like the best student like going to
school and you know getting grades and
stuff like that more I just been
following my interests now in listicle
classes that I was interested in I
always did really well in other classes
I may not even care about the class you
know but I saw I was I wouldn't say I
was like studying but I would just
follow my interests so your dad died
when you were 12 so you must have been
in like eighth grade seventh grade we're
great is that
yeah seventh grade seventh grade so that
was really pivotal because you know you
get taken out of school because your dad
died and then when you go back to school
in the seventh grade
you're the kid whose dad died and I mean
and you know and you know it and you
know everybody else knows it and you're
just kind of like you know to yourself
more so I had some good friends like I
used to I was into like I had some nerd
friends you know like Dungeons and
Dragons that kind of stuff you know so I
would kind of hang out with them but it
was only you know on breaks at school or
something like that
there would you do it like what would
you do the rest of the day what would
you do in the afternoon what would you
do in the evening what would you do on
the weekends come home like at that age
after school come home watch like was it
Thundercats
oh yeah remember that remember that that
we had to go picks picks picks like was
that it was something to do
win these prizes yeah yeah yeah that you
got a phone-in yeah yeah someone had to
phone in and call for fire by saying
picks picks on the local TV station
yeah I do remember that dang yet I don't
think that was that was didn't have that
echo did you yeah in the bill at all
cuz you I think you might be younger
yeah but and also I don't think they had
that was like a local TV thing yeah
they had like a little echo they had
like a little call for fire so you'd be
on the phone you'd have to call in while
you watching TV yeah and it was like a
video game of some kind where you had to
drop bombs or shoot something but at a
certain time as it was moving so when it
moved you'd say picks picks picks that
that was like fire it was like maybe the
maybe the channel like on TV you know
how it's like w lb n or whatever this
was WPIX or something just say picks
banks so now I know who's trying to call
wait that was the other funny thing
about mark and James is they'd see you
and I remember that's why that's why to
this day whenever I see you I go yeah
and that's right because they'd see you
and they call you out did you ever
reconcile some kind of relationship with
those guys
no because those guys are more like you
know cool guys in a sense you know they
were popular people and I was there is
just really no connection you know and
and it was really weird cuz in the
projects the the atmosphere you know
it's like R&B jazz hip-hop but James was
like into metal him
they're like maybe like just a fraction
of people in there that that were into
metal and he was into the metal he'd
have Iron Maiden shirts on and all that
stuff and just becoming act and he'd
give you the corner and just he'd
started punching away and then asked me
do you want the medicine or the
treatment and both were the same movie
yeah I remember you tell me you'd like
be you think you have you think you
would have made it past them or whatever
and you'd be going up the stairs and all
of a sudden you'd hear yeah
and there was another one you told me
about something like you were walking it
was dark in your walk I think you were
walking down the stairs and as you came
down the stairs one of them whichever
one was lit a match okay yeah yeah
so that was James - in is essentially um
you know every now and then you get
blackouts you know the city and we had
this big blackout back then and that's a
problem because now the elevator might
not be working so if you live on the 8th
floor you have to walk up and there are
some elderly people that live like 7th
8th floor and so we're like you know hey
you know get a knife and you could make
a dollar or two welcome people upstairs
then so you know I was walking people I
walked maybe one or two people upstairs
and then I was coming downstairs and all
of a sudden you tip out man and he just
lit a match and there was there was
James and then more punishment it's
about magic wonder yeah take your breath
away this is a Broadway play okay what's
going on that at that time okay that
part I never knew all I ever knew all I
remembered from buds was it's about
magic wonder - I've never heard I
thought it was just what those guys made
up like goose this yeah just sigh CONUS
so these guys never you never reconcile
with these guys there's no story of
revenge where you went back not really
you know and and I'd you know looking
back right now I wouldn't even you know
I don't really have anything for those
guys you know I'm just I wish everybody
the best so you know it's just past what
music were you listening to back then I
only listened to what was there so it
was like a lot of rap music you know R&B
you know just they
music and I got introduced to other
forms of music by first I played
saxophone as he could so I played
saxophone for like four years so I was
like got involved with like Orchestra
like I would my dad set me up for a
summer program and I would go and play
in a symphonic orchestra for over the
summer said I'd like take out a bus you
know and you know I take my saxophone
along it was pretty cool that and also
my dad liked jazz so that was also
another influence on you know my musical
tastes and then the kids some of the
kids I played Dungeons & Dragons with
there were some groups like one group
was like the Brewster Street crew of
those guys and then there was another
group and these guys they were all into
like metal and stuff because when you go
to you know the schools over there kind
of like is owned so they have people
from different neighborhoods coming to
the schools so these these were these
kids were not from the projects and they
listen to metal and like when we would
play dungeon dragons that music was
there and I was like it just became
normal so I was like you know and and
also I wanted to always wanted to try
different things you know and see you
know what's that like so it's kind of
exploring and so I started listening to
you know any kind of music I wanted to
listen to I was interested in and I
check it out now at what point did you
start thinking about the military as an
option okay after my father passed away
there was a my father's good friend this
guy James Harrison mr. Jim we used to
call him he was his son came back from
the Navy he was a regular guy in the
Navy and he told me about the seals
because I think I'd seen at this point
I'd seen first blood you know I was like
I'm coming
my you know I started finding out about
the different military units and so I'm
like my original plan was to go and
agree going the Rangers then become a
green beret and then I heard about Force
Recon then I'm gonna go on the reins and
become Force Recon and then once I read
about seals going to seals and become a
seal like I wanted to be all the special
forces but this you know Jamie his son
that guy really changed my life because
he told me about the seals and and I was
like well wouldn't you know that Navy
with a speedboat drivers I couldn't
think of what in the Navy could be spec
ops and then he started telling me about
it
and I was like man that's like I need to
find out more about it and so I went to
the recruiter and at this point I'm like
you know mid-teens and I asked the
recruiter about the seals and he said
don't even think about it cuz you'll
never make it and that was like that's
when I was like oh yeah
and then I started like really focusing
on trying to get into SEAL team so mr.
Jim was along with my father they would
teach boxing to like the kids like
troubled youth it's tough that these
areas you know they had a heavy bag and
my dad was a boxer and yeah mr. Jim
started training me I said I wanted to
go into seals and he's like hey you know
if you want to get into condition meet
me down here on the park bench at four
o'clock and it's like mid winter in New
York snow and stuff like that and he's
like if you're not here at 4:00 on the
dot
I know you're not serious you know we
don't have to talk about it again and
I'm like alright and you know there was
the first time ever like woke up early
like that was four o'clock in the
morning yeah oh he's a good test I got
out there after would have failed before
o'clock p.m.
no problem mr. Jim yeah he started
training me and it was like push-ups
dips on the park bench and like when you
go into the buildings and what's
Brighton at least this kind of like this
overhang doing pull-ups on that and it's
like you know if you're gonna be a
fighter you need to keep your hands up
that's the first rule of fighting so you
know we go out there was this field
across the way and uh he'd happen you
running laps around the football field
with bricks in my hands and the goal was
learned how to keep your hands up and
you know the first few weeks is bricks
you know I'd meet him like two three
times a week doing this and then
graduate it to like you know milk jugs
pouring water in him and then the milks
jostling around as you run around you
know and he really just teaches really
instilled in me you know like you have
to train you know if you want to if you
want to get something you're gonna have
to work for it so I I worked with them
and then at a certain point I was uh 17
at the time and I just chose to go live
with my mom because I was like you know
I'm just really curious you know there
were a lot of things in my mind that you
know I didn't really know my mom like I
think I should I should have and so I
wanted to know more about that side of
my family so I went and moved with my
mom and she wanted me out of the
projects and so we moved down to Florida
Daytona Beach so my senior year of high
school was in Daytona Beach Florida it
was a weird thing because my high school
the first year of high school I went to
art design in Manhattan so I had to take
a bus a boat and a train to and from
school every day so I take the three bus
down the ferry take the Staten Island
ferry across take the four of the five
up to 57th and Washington go to school
and you know I was oh
drawing and stuff like that so um I got
into this art school I went there for a
year but it did it um
I didn't do while I was coming in late
and it just wasn't a good fit and I
ended up leaving that school and then I
went to my zone school
Susan Wagner for two years so tenth and
eleventh and then I won with my mom and
moved down to Daytona Beach and I went
to Seabreeze senior high school in
Daytona Beach so my that was my senior
year and when I was there that's when I
enlisted on the delayed Entry Program
and got into other Navy did you play any
sports at any of these schools no did
you what it's weird how you had that it
makes me you think it runs deeper than
I've even thought before like the idea
of when you saw Rambo you're like you
can identify with it even though you
were a nerd playing Dungeons & Dragons
and looking at spider books you see
Rambo you're like okay cool that's what
I'm gonna do that's a deep-seeded thing
man I think looking back on it James had
a lot to do with it mark and James cuz
like getting beat up like that at a
certain point you just like you know
you've had enough and then you kind of I
think in a sense can overcompensate so I
started learning about martial arts
another really big part of you know my
story is uh my oldest brother was you
know we had a big family incident he was
out side and a guy in there's West Brian
projects right near it is Malcolm Holmes
it's another pretty rough area and my
brother was there and this guy stabbed
him with a buck double-oh-seven knife
that's a big blade to the hilt
and you know his heart was was beating
you know moving the knife you know
punctured his lung and he was in the
hospital for a while he got out you know
you know doctors saved his life and all
he's got a really big scar on his chest
but I mean I think he he got into kung
fu' from that I would say and you know
he went all the way to being an
instructor in that but you know he would
show me you know occasionally on on a
weekends sometimes I would go with him
and train you know I'm hung gar kung fu
and I was never really you know I've
never really got good at it but it did
instill in me you know martial arts
something you want to learn mm-hmm and
so um you know I had those things going
for me and I think between learning a
little bit about martial arts and you
know the beatings I was taken at a
certain point I was like you know I can
change it if I want so my thing was to
become a seal I thought that would be my
answer so that's why I went see so you
the Florida what was it like on a school
in Florida I mean sea breeze the high
school sounds it sounds nice it sounds
nice but what was it I mean was it nice
or was it a jumper yeah it was pretty
cool um it was uh definitely more
laid-back than a being in New York I
remember distinctly at that time Ted
Bundy was in that area and the chaplain
at our school was I think associated
with Ted Bundy and I just remember he
was getting the electric chair and and
everyone in the school was like make
sure you keep all your electrical
components to flow so they have enough
juice did you talk to when you talk to
the recruiter so you had to talk to a
recruiter again in Florida right you
obviously had a change recur what the
recruiter said you the recruiters were
all about getting as many people in his
pops and like you want to go see all
right come over here and you look like
I'd be a great candidate yeah that's
where I was surprised the first guy told
you he didn't think you're gonna make it
although JP Danelle they laughed at him
yeah they laughed at him maybe that's a
good test and Dakota Meyer the guy said
to for the Marine Corps said you
we don't have what it takes anyways and
Dakota Meyer signing up the next day or
whatever right that's a good it's a
little reverse psychology oh yeah but
they told you oh yeah you look like be
up great candidate for the SEAL Teams
they're waiting for you yeah we have the
the Thai ferret program and the dive
fair program I don't deprive something
similar today but you enlist
for six years and if you make it through
but straining and your SEAL training
then you're on SEAL team if you don't
make it you're still in the Navy
persecutors I did the dive fair program
too and it's funny too because when you
taught when it seemed like six years
it's well that's like an eighth or sorry
a third of your life at the time right
because you're 18 years old and you're
saying I'm signing on this thing for six
years and you and me I don't know about
you I'm pretty sure you're probably the
same way I had no idea whatsoever what
the daily life of a seal was as far as
I'm concerned at war I was like well
it's got to be pretty similar to John
Jay Rambo right yeah it's gonna be
something like that we're gonna be out
just hunting people down and killing
them that's what's gonna be happening
six years cool sign me up you have no
idea what you're getting into which is
kind of cool
because I just about guarantee that
anybody that had an eye anybody have
thought about what they were getting
into you thought it was gonna be way
more extreme than anything all that you
could have did anything it actually was
I I mean I remember the stories of yeah
when you're in SEAL training they bury
you up up to your neck in the sand and
let the tide come in and drown you and
then they resuscitate you and then ask
you if you want to quit and I was like
yeah yeah that's the program that's you
know what I remember is a guy that ended
up he was actually ended up in a class
behind us but I went through boot camp
with him and he was a smart guy went to
college great guy and he's telling me he
goes yeah shields have 50% casualty rate
like that like no one makes the
retirement
this is 99 you know there's no I mean I
guess the Gulf War is about to happen
but there had been a war in a long time
and I think I think it came originally
from World War two when like at Normandy
the you DTS took heavy cab they took
like a 50% casually rate but I thought
that's just how I thought I was going in
I'm signing up and I'm gonna get killed
or wounded and I'm probably not gonna
make it 20 years whatever same attitude
oh yeah you definitely heard that they
drowned you you definitely heard that
they drowned you in training you're
gonna get drowned it people are gonna
drown you
that's what's gonna happen you're like
yeah that's what I want which is pretty
crazy right yeah it seems like it even
that's a good kind of screening process
an initial screening process the crazy
thing is so many people still quit
that's what's crazy you know what you're
signing up for you know what you're
signing up for at least you have someone
you're signing up to die
I mean I can say I was signing up to die
I'm like in my mind I was like okay when
I sign this paper you know my life is no
longer it is no longer a promise it's no
longer even a thing
yeah you I mean you are an adult even
though a very young adult but you
understand what you getting into and you
know the chances of getting killed or or
her really badly or you know can happen
anything else from childhood Before we
jump in Doug before we get the the ended
boot camp hmm nothing of note on them at
this point
you said you finish up your senior what
kind of training are you doing getting
ready putting my backpack and sometimes
I would run to school I'm doing a one
incident I got saved at the beach
so this I is this tropical storm coming
in and I you know keep in mind I'm
coming from the projects in New York
City so swimming is not I'm not a good
swimmer
and I'm like well the best way to learn
you know is to go
tropical storm baby I just remember
getting out of getting out and looking
at the beach and just seeing the water
like frothy and stuff and I was just
like let's go for it and I just ran in
and basically I was a drowning victim
this guy came out getting out of water
started yelling at me and stuff like
that so then I came home I'm like you
know I told my my i want to take swim
lessons so then the only place we could
find was the YWCA and this this I could
I think she was like maybe a college
student you know I just would see this
girls writing notes and stuff on the
side with a textbook but she was the
guard there and she taught me how to
swim so I learned the side stroke like
basic side stroke not a combat swimmer
stroke and a brush stroke crawl you know
like the technique of it mm-hmm and
while I was doing that I I got books on
swimming workouts how to swim how to you
know get um more hydrodynamic this kind
of thing
how much swimming did you do in the
projects not really any I mean like in
the summer there's a pool right near it
the pool is three feet mm-hmm and then
they have a little baby pool so that was
another thing about mark and James when
when the when I would go to the pool I
mean I mean on several occasions I mean
James if you're out there listening your
home would kill me a couple of times and
I'm not kidding he would you know
there's like a ladder you could walk out
he would get me under there and stand on
me and hold me there like trying to
drown me and the worst feeling I ever
had was like just you know I'm in the
water and like I'm bouncing like bobbing
because it's too deep and I just hear
and I look over and I see him on the
side for you and then you jump in and
come after them trying to get out you
know trying to hop away and then I look
over and then it's mark and then you
know I would you know the lifeguards
would you know have to get these guys
away from me so yeah I did I was not a
the swimming extent was like close your
eyes
windmill until you can't hold your
breath anymore and then stand and
hopefully there's a bottom to stand on
how did you uh dude how did you not get
freaking discouraged after you almost
drown and you don't know how to swim and
you must be at least seeing that the
seal test to is who do we have to swim
500 meters 500 yards to like go to buds
yeah how did you not say maybe I need to
look at the Rangers or maybe I need to
look at the Special Forces or something
I was just really bent on the seals and
that was just um that was the one back
then like now there's a lot of
information on SEAL team but back then
you couldn't find anything there and and
I remember you there are these books
like I'd get like the Ranger book and
then you'd open it up and you'd see like
they had Green Berets seals Force Recon
and then you look like when you try to
find the seal book no one had it and it
was like the mystery mm-hmm so I was
like you know I think I want to I want
to go with that one
so you're how long were you in the
delayed Entry Program for let's see I
graduated high school
like that spring time and I was in the
Navy in August it was pretty quick yeah
I went in pretty much right after high
school so that that um I had like maybe
a two-month period of really swimming
that's what I was working on and you
know I was doing push-ups and finding
like the screening tests or working on
pull ups and sit ups you know all the
basics you need for blood running mm-hmm
then you said you shipped off did you go
to boot camp in Orlando right Orlando
yeah how was that a shock to your system
I think the main shock was just the
first like wake up
but then after that you know I was
pretty smooth it wasn't really that big
a deal I was in a Duke boot camp hey so
I was in the new boot camp and it was
like myself and this other guy's name
was justice we were both going to the
seals and so we were like old doser to
seal guys you know over there we didn't
we'd you know in boot camp my swim was
still not qualifying so they were like
hey you if you serious about this
program you get up at 3:30 go over there
to the pool and do your laps before you
know the regular day of boot camp starts
so I was like I did that throughout boot
camp and really improved my swimming and
there was a you know they had sealed
motivators working there and there was a
seal Vietnam vet you know rough dude
there and uh he was uh he would kind of
you know oversee the swimming he would
watch me and stuff and he would be
saying stuff like you'll never make it
with that kind of structure just never
make it and I had I had an issue with
him because you know III my swim was
like just on the edge I failed so I knew
I could pass that I just needed to be
faster push up some good sit-ups but my
pull-ups were like on the edge too and
so I remember like getting I got seven
and then I got eight was like right here
and he just counted seven and I tried
again and you like with pull-ups once
you fail you're not going the dog and I
just stayed on the bar and he said all
right recruit jump off the bar and I
yelled out so you'll stand quit and he
just he just laid into me screaming it's
tough so I jumped off the bar and then I
I knew I had to walk on the pull-ups so
they had a gym there and what I did was
that I was during boot camp all this
happened yeah I don't
they taking a screening test a one time
yeah I took it
my I think like two to three times so
then the the because if you don't make
it for buds you know there was you conic
okay now you can go divert or EOD so I
ended up working on a pulldown machine
and that's how I got my pull-ups so then
by actually by the by the end of boot
camp I passed the tests and ended up you
know with orders what so then you get
two buds
do you remember checking into buds yeah
that's another thing so when I was in
boot camp and I get to yep back then you
had to go through your source rating so
I was in engineering so I had to go to
Great Lakes and go through engineman a
school this is like the trade that
you're gonna get if you don't make it
through SEAL training you're gonna work
in the job in the regular Navy and so I
went to Great Lakes and went through a
and a school and my vision didn't
qualify for buds day so this is kind of
like gonna maybe put me in hot water
with some people but essentially I ended
up passing the vision test through some
nefarious methods how'd you do it so
essentially what happened was I had
orders to yo D training because your
vision wasn't good enough right for but
so everything well it was good enough
but my vision you know I you know
glasses so one of the one of the guys
there that Worthen one of the dive
motivators Steve Collins that another
really pivotal person in my life he was
like hey man if you really interested in
going the shield training you know we
can work on switching your orders and
you'll have to work as a you know for us
as you know the dive motivator Shaq I
was like yeah of course and so I did it
and I had to wait like
it was like months like gonna say like
at least six months day and I worked for
these dive motivators just slowly seeing
for your vision test and here's the deal
they have the medical was right near it
and the vision tests that have to take
is right there on the wall so every day
I'm just looking at it and memorizing
all of the you know the letters and
numbers
mm-hmm and I ended up passing the test
so you that's awesome and and this whole
time you're obviously working out and
getting in shape and these guys are
telling you what to do and what to be
prepared for and all that stuff
yeah that was another big deal like
George white Steve Collins instructor
Roberts these guys really made a
difference because they were like hey
you know they weren't like you know
showing me everything but they're like
you have to do this this is gonna help
you you need to run you need to do this
and that and what was really bad was at
a certain point you know team guys work
in that dive motivator Shack they don't
want to do it and so they're like Higgs
he's a blue and gold some judy judy T
trunks so I'm looking like a seal right
I got the blue and gold you DeeDee
trunks and the boots on and everything
and dive socks and they're like you're
gonna give the test so for six months
I'm working at the dive motivators and
pretending to be a seal yeah yeah pretty
much they're like hey you know Higgs
what's what's it like it's a team and
they're like let's not talk about what
you have to worry about is getting
through the screening test so I would
run that they would do that runs they
would do the push-ups all the stuff I
would test them and just record it and
six months of that and then when I get
the buds
you got like dozens and dozens of guys
you're like hey that's the dive
motivator guy I'm just saying
so you check into buds I don't worry you
know what's weird is I don't really
remember you know some people have
really good checking into bud stories or
whatever like they check in and they get
immediately told to hit the surf in
their dress whites or whatever
for whatever reason man I don't really
even remember checking in a bus I think
it was a weekend I think no one cared
you know and I was the biggest thing for
me as I was kind of surprised you know I
expected to walk through the quarterdeck
and just get ripped apart and start
becoming a different you know you know
like the James Bond movie echo Charles
you know where the door opens and
there's people training and they're
doing judo and they're shooting guns
what's happening but instead I open up
the door and there's the two new two
other guys that are going through
training and they're sitting there all
scared looking and there's no one around
and I said I'm checking in the buds and
they're like okay now you can just sign
this and then you come back on Monday
and I was kind of let down as very
anti-climactic
some people get a much but how did you
was anything cool for you yeah I think
um I showed up on the quarterdeck and
someone was getting hammered there
because I showed up during the day
during a weekday and guys getting
hammered and yelled at and instructor to
just look at me and like you know here
I'm like gosh yes and they just saying
good we'll be seeing ya you know and
just walk off you know and I'm like oh
really
so then how long did it take for you to
class up oh it was I went through I
don't know if they do this these days
but they had the fourth phase when I was
in fourth phase and you just wait there
into your class up so I originally
classed up with buds class 1 7 for how
far did you make it in 174 all the way
to the day before hell week and then
what happened
so you have like basically you're going
through first phase like the
conditioning phase of buds doing lots of
long run swims
PT's Oh course all that stuff and um I
ended up doing this one swim like a week
before that last week
and on the swim my-my-my facemask one of
the one of the lenses fell out and I
just the water was it was a super choppy
swim so every every stroke might taking
on water and then I have no you know
it's I can't really see much and it's
making me go slower for my swim buddy
and everything and I just felt sick on
the swim like nauseated and really weak
and tired like not normal and when I got
out of the water you know we just got
hammered because we failed the swim and
then I had to go in and you know do just
getting hammered and so it was uh that
was like on a Thursday it's in the
weekend and then Tuesday comes along and
then we got to do the two-mile swims
ocean swim and then on that swim i
coming back past the swim when i came
out of the water I couldn't stand i was
just falling and i was crawling that
would stand up and fall over again and
the instructors just swarmed on me and
just started trying to have i mean i'm
trying to do push-ups or whatever but I
just couldn't and then then I start
laughing like it was funny I was like my
first experience of being inebriated
because I was basically you know find
out later add hypothermia so I got I had
a 91 degree core temperature at that
point and day so they brought me you
know to the hypothermia chamber and
that's basically a hot tub and get my
body temperature back up and then it's
like you know you're feeling better yeah
all right this is seal training so go
get wet and Sandy you know right after
coming back to normal and then they're
like that night I just remembers you
know mine in the rack and thinking like
you know medically I'm having some
issues here and how am I going to get
through there's another swim and then
they just
longer you know so I just remembered
tossing and turning and then of the
everyone in the class was like trying to
help me out so like you know back then
you got to take pantothenic acid pills
like this B vitamin that's supposed to
increase thermogenesis to make your body
heat up and so uh and then you need lots
of calories so what we did on this one
swim before it everyone came in put
Vaseline all over it then my wetsuit and
then drink a bottle of olive oil for
calories to help burn during the swim
and well that's not a good idea I didn't
quite finish the bottle of olive oil but
I can tell you right now it's not a good
idea so one you know we're doing swim
inspection and the instructors are you
know checking knives co2 cartridges and
the instructor looks and they see the
Vaseline on the end of the sleeve like
what is this and he pulls it up and he
sees it Vaseline take your wet suit off
and then roll around in the sand and
then put the wet suit back on and then
do this one and so uh I did so it's like
this two-mile ocean swim just like every
you know at a certain point it's just
the sands just destroying your skin and
everything and this is seal training
yeah so I came out and I had hypothermia
again and you know at this time it was a
lot different because I was like you
know I was like my body's not working
the way I wanted to you know it's I'm
not quitting it's like I don't even have
control of the situation and essentially
uh at that point they're like you know
you can't continue in the training
you're gonna get killed
you know they had a someone a few
classes ahead who had died out in San
Clemente they you know he did a swim a
four mile ocean swim came out of the
water and just fell down and
in making so like you know and this
guy's his body temperature was only a
few degrees below mine so they were like
you know you're medically dropped from
training and so I was a that was of on
that Friday then the hell week starts
for that class I was in that Sunday and
I just remember being in my room like
with the lights off and like you know
feeling of could I you know and all the
class was going through hell week and I
just I wasn't allowed in and you know
there was some you know when I when I
was medically dropped I just started to
do my own training because I was you
know now I'm an X Division so I got the
the Navy
garb on the white had the dunker G
younger jams dungaree clothing and I'm
doing watch one of the instructors came
by and said hey I always I knew you'd
quit sooner or later
now as I didn't quit it's like yeah you
did and then walked off and that just
like got me angry so I was like I'm
gonna do my own training so I started
doing I would join the class and run
behind them you know I was just being a
part of the class doing cadence and
everything and I went got wet in Sandy
and then instructor Dumas remember him
there he just pulled me aside and I was
like it's over son it's over and and
that was it and so I had orders to some
ship in like Louisiana or something like
that and uh but the instructors that saw
me getting wet in Sandy they were like
oh look at this kid you know and there
was an instructor named chief small and
he said if you want your writing
requests for captain's mess and I'll try
to get you in training I'll put in a
good word for you and get you back in
the training and I was like yeah and so
I would write the request but now I'm in
X Division so I'm working for that guy
powered mmm-hmm and this is an old
Vietnam vet rough
I mean it's hard for me to do just as
what this guy you know what this guy was
like and he would just take my request
and throw it in the garbage and he just
kept doing it and he would just just
yell at me you'll never make it through
this program son get the hell out of
here
and uh the guy chief small I told him
about it he took it up to the CEO and um
I got captain's mast and Lieutenant
Zinke was I think part of that and those
guys they said hey we're gonna give you
another chance cuz I was explaining you
know I didn't quit the training I got
medically dropped like hey if you can
gain weight cuz I'm like at that point
I'm 6 1 but I wait I've looked at my
medical record I weighed like 153 and
you know that's just not enough mass to
get you through the cult of being a
fraud man it's just not gonna it's gonna
be tough so they they're like hey it was
Christmastime Merry Christmas you're
back in training go get wet and uh I
started up in a class 176 like a couple
months later so that that time I was uh
that in-between time of classing up I
just focused on gaining weight so I
would uh was really strange for a lot of
people you can order pizza inputs like
when everything's over
you can order pizza in buds and and so I
would I was like you know I have to gain
weight so you know on some time off I
got a big thing of that weight gain
powder I got a bunch of milk like whole
milk and I would order two-for-one
Domino's Pizza hmm and I was just
constantly drinking the milk with the
weight gain I would eat a pizza before I
went to sleep with the weight gain and
the milk sent my clock for 3:00 in the
morning and eat the other pizza you know
this it got disgusting yellow and at a
certain point like I'm not a pizza fan
anymore but I ended up by the time I
classed up I was like like 170 you know
I'd gained weight
and I'm then I classed up in Boyd's
class 176 and then and came to more
difficulties with pool comp and then I
got rolled into 177 your class and I
wasn't even poke on it was it was um uh
like dive buddy cuz I was like already
breathing or something yeah I was with
Matt okay did both you guys get rolled
for that yeah so so you you didn't get
rolled into our class until now second
phase yeah die face so I went through
hell week in 176 the hardest hell week
that that ever really existed in butts
yes that's a seven six guys know this
stuff so then you rolled into our class
and yeah the no one really told no there
was no heads up whatsoever about like
the pool comp and all that stuff that's
something no one really knows they know
about it now but back then they had that
Texas Chainsaw Massacre poster in the
medical area and it said but it was
crossed out it's crossed out uh Texas it
said buds pool comp Massacre and it had
like a mask on one of the guys that was
getting his head sawn off with a
chainsaw and that's what pool comp is
you know you're gonna go down there and
you're gonna get annihilated I tell you
I mean it's it's really hard to do it
justice like basically it's not a matter
of pain it's a matter of dealing with
not being able to breathe like if and
and you're on compressed air if you hold
your breath and rock it to the surface
you're gonna embolize it and hurt
yourself badly you know so you have to
have that control and the instructors
are taking your mask off tying your your
gear and knots and you have to get these
knots out I mean the other thing is
though they're using the old regulators
from the 50s like Jacques Cousteau so
you can close it and you can't breathe
so they they're taking this regulator
out that filled with water and then you
got it you got it
turn your head
get the water out or blow it out and
their Tiny's see these knots in you have
to get it out it's just it's horrific
and it lasts a long time
yeah it's 30 minutes your first breath
is Walker so because when they rip that
regulator out of your mouth the hose
fills with water so when you put it in
your mouth you can't just Oh No well
your first breath is you gotta like
absorb the water and get it out and then
you get a breath so you're you're in
full panic mode as you're trying to get
the knot untied you finally get it
untied and now you're just just dying
for air and you put that thing in your
mouth and you still have to clear that
thing it's it's really it's where I
failed I failed pool comp my first time
and then I don't know when you with us
in the dip tank cuz over the weekend
myself and a few other guys that failed
did you pass it the first time when he
went through with 177 did you pass pool
comp no I did not
oh no and what happened with you
remember Anson Davies
yeah we got out on that weekend because
you know we had failed you're on the
wall of shame and we went down to Mexico
to do dive training yeah and we we were
like I was so weird was you know in
Mexico the the beach had all this life
on it that you don't see here you know
but it's essentially the same Beach just
further down but you know we did uh we
kind of like worked on it ourselves for
a bit and then came back and I just
remember that that Sunday night thinking
of everyone's just tossing and turning
in their bed cuz you're like am I gonna
make it through this the next day you
know and I was able to you know I did it
yeah yeah we what we did and I'm not
sure how you weren't with us but it was
me and like three or four other guys
that failed pool comp on Friday and we
went in the big dip tank and we
straight-up drowned each other we were
just murdering each other in there and
clear and stuff and man I was so
horrified of not making it and of
getting role you know cuz I don't even
think about getting rolled it's like as
far as I was concerned if I got rolled
that seemed like just death you know it
seemed like the worst thing ever but we
pool comped each other so hard that all
of us made it the first time on Monday
morning like it was no factor so that
extra a little bit of training weather
in Mexico or weather in the dip tank
I also they let us do it like the
instructors I don't know how he did it I
don't know what happened that we had all
the gear like we got full scuba tanks
with air and brought them into the dip
tank and just murdered each other I
don't know that's not legal you know
like that's not okay you can't do that
that's like if you if they change yeah
they're just like there's an opening
right there if you take the opportunity
good on you if you don't so sorry so
sorry yeah so we end up you end up in
our class
and that's funny I actually thought you
did everything with us I thought I
thought you got rolled into 177 I
thought you went through hell week with
us I didn't remember that I remember
that you got rolled in in you know die
face cuz yeah so then we did San
Clemente Island chewing tobacco yeah
that's not a fun that they found guys
you're not allowed to have chewing
tobacco out there and they found
somebody had smuggled a bunch out a
bunch and so they made everyone in the
class take massive chunks of chewing
tobacco and then we did like a thousand
eight cow bodybuilders which is like an
old-school Burpee and like me I did I
never chewed tobacco and never smoked a
cigarette and and all of a sudden I got
a big mouthful of this
yeah I haven't dipped since that was my
one and only jealousy that was your
opportunity does it like Jam you know
like when you dip and you haven't ever
does it like you feel like actual
effects right like way strong like it
jams you up kind of hard they dip yeah
that stuff makes you feel sick yeah
maybe I feel sick yeah burning in my
mouth yeah yeah but you know how like
okay let's say you never smoked a
cigarette ever and then you straight up
smoke a whole cigarette you're gonna be
like buzzing kind of hardcore right were
you buzzing from the dip is what I'm
saying I didn't know that and pain in
this thing like this is horrible
yeah but yeah like like you said Jeff it
cured me of ever wanting to do that well
I think it's important to know like you
know in SpecOps a lot of guys are gonna
use dip chewing tobacco because of that
reason it's like a little bit of you
know yeah what do you meant anything
else from saying company Island besides
good times and flights I'm on fire
requested to do a touch-and-go you do
they still do that like the fried frog
he'll they still do frog he'll they
still do flights they still got a flight
tower out there you still be touching
goes the whole nine yards yeah it's good
times make you tough so then you get
that we got on with buds you check in a
SEAL team and so one it's 1991 when we
get to SEAL team one yeah it's early
1991 did we go too did we go to Airborne
School together yeah went to get our
airborne on Fort Benning yeah so that's
different too nowadays but back then you
went to army jump school there's what
Benny showed you and that's where seals
get like a horrible I guess kind of a
horrible reputation because like you're
coming out of buds day you'd go to
Airborne School which airborne is a very
conventional school to go to like every
one of the like a lot of it not everyone
but a lot of people go to the go to the
army jump school so there's no super
high standard for physicality or
anything so when you get down you're
fresh out of seal training and you're
down there just feel like you can do
anything
and of course the the black hats which
are the instructors down there they did
you know they call everyone Navy if like
all every guy that's not in the army
that is called you Navy
I never that come on over here Navy beat
your boots that was another thing to
make you do squats they say beat your
boots and you basically got to hit your
boots but it's pretty fun school I had a
good time yeah yeah airborne was cool
and then um and then we check in a SEAL
team one and you and well we went
through sqt together or stt used to be
called zeal tactical training yes that
was just learning all the stuff that you
actually where I wanted to actually
learn I'm sure we all just wanted to
learn how to shoot move and communicate
out of patrol explosives like this is
when you start doing cooler stuff
besides key being wet and Sandy yes and
then from there we roll into our
platoons your and my sister platoon you
call it brother pretend okay fair enough
well know where they call it sister
platoon they do
they never call it brother platoon hmm I
mean like stores they'll do that too
that's our sister store yeah we never
saved another store even in the teams
where there's no females and we say
brother what's up with that I mean we
say sister so you guys are in our
brother platoon apparently now or system
and we're doing work up you know it's a
different environment
I remember your platoon your platoon had
some let's just say pipe hitters in it
right um you guys had some heavy hitters
that pull - yeah more Sullivan in my 1st
platoon we had great guys my first Atun
but the guys that you had in your
platoon were harder I'm straight up
there's no real other way of putting it
they were harder on you guys for sure
yeah I mean I'm lucky in the sense that
I wasn't the main target I mean I was
targeted I mean there was a situation we
had down and
in Panama like with the hazing that was
really extreme you know and you know
some some injuries happen I got choked
out at least five times that night at
least there and yeah beaten you know it
was that platoon was pretty hardcore
yeah I've told a story on this podcast
couple times about like when I got to
the team and um um sitting out by the
pool or I'm out doing a workout on the
pull-up bar and this giant human like
barely human goes lumbering out across
the it's probably 200 year maybe even a
hundred yards from like the team area to
first lieutenant where the engines are
and it's a guy from your platoon you
know who it is the biggest guy in your
platoon yeah and he's carrying a gallon
of milk with him and so he's lumbering
across this giant guy with this whole
body tattooed no shirt on and he stops
like at the 50 meter mark and drinks a
half a gallon of milk he keeps walking
and I'm like how am I gonna survive in
this environment because it was just it
was a very hostile environment back then
you know very hostile and in the SEAL
platoons and and you know what a lot but
not a lot of it so let's just say some
of it was wrong some of it like some of
it got taken to a point where it was not
good for morale it wasn't good for unity
you know some of the hazing got to a
point where you're like hey that that's
not that's not okay like that's wrong
some of its good you know some of it's
okay you know welcome to the teams and
it's a rough environment if you screw up
you're gonna pay but yeah some of it
went overboard but yeah you had a you
had a you had a hardcore platoon and
when we when we got overseas we were you
know what I remember is on old an old
master chief who seemed like the oldest
guy I had ever seen in my life which was
Steve Bailey you know and he was
probably like seven years younger eight
years younger than I am right now he's
probably like 40 but he seems so old and
he's like does anyone here want to learn
how to fight and I'm like yep me and I I
don't know if we were to get
when that happened but we ended up in
the Kwan's in hut with mats on the
ground that he knew enough jiu-jitsu he
was like a white belt
no I my recollection is different so the
first deployment overseas that platoon
that we were just talking about we went
to Guam and then flew straight to
Thailand okay and we were in Thailand
and that's where I met Steve we're
talking about and basically I got
introduced to jiu-jitsu there and then
we got back to Guam you know continue
the training okay well it's kind of
weird 1991 mm-hmm and I got introduced
to jujitsu Brazilian Jiu Jitsu in
Thailand yeah in 91 and then actually as
92 yeah there and then coming back to
Guam started at the Quonset hut yeah so
so that must have happened cuz you went
right away to Thailand yeah I'm in SIL
and Guam you everyone comes back from
Thailand including Steve Bailey and then
when he came back he must have said hey
who wants to learn jujitsu I raised my
hand you know he I think he he's who
wants to learn how to fight cuz I think
him asking who wants to learn jujitsu
would have been the most you know would
have been like oh is this a language is
this up I don't even know so it was more
like hey who wants to learn how to fight
I'm like of course and then I just
remember him just choking us out I mean
and everything just like with three or
four different moves you know I was like
oh he knew it may be an armlock and
Americana may be like the sit up sweep
he didn't there wasn't a ton of
different things I can do how to take
the back but it wasn't this it seemed
like a little imited number of moves
that jujitsu was it wasn't as involved
as it as it is now for sure were you
already making the connection I didn't
even make the connection I thought oh
there's in my mind I thought jujitsu was
seven moves like I you know or whatever
maybe when you get advanced there's 12
you know what I mean I just thought okay
there's seven moves here they are
practice them and then you know jujitsu
I didn't I didn't make the connection
between
that what we were learning and this
whole freaking crazy sport although my
training with Steve was a really pivotal
time in my life you know he introduced
me to jiu-jitsu that's really changed my
life in a really awesome way but also
like there was a lot of striking - we
did a kickboxing and you know III that's
what actually solidified my my journey
in jiu-jitsu because you know he had a
few black belts that had trained under
him other team guys and we would do we
were doing sparring at this point when
we'd come back home and I would go down
there and like for two years at least a
trend three times a week there and it
was one day striking and then the next
day we do ground and I got and then like
on a Friday we do like just sparring it
so it's like SEAL team all the other
guys are black belts and I'm like the
new guy and it's just like the goal is
to knock the new guy out you know and
and um I got my jaw dislocated by one of
the guys I came in on him and he turned
around it's big hook kick right my chin
and I fell forward he turned his back no
hooks or nothing I just put the choke on
and I choked them but then after that I
couldn't remember what day it was my
back teeth weren't touching and um I had
my chin was just swollen and I had to
like wait around for a while so I had
like the wherewithal to get back home
but that was like kind of like pivotal
because I was like you know even when I
was hurt did you Jitsu goes on fuel and
sometimes when you don't have your
senses if you can just feel what's going
on you you have a chance and so that was
a big lesson for me and that's after we
got home so after we got home you were
state you were staying engaged in
jiu-jitsu when I got home I didn't and I
think part of its because I just thought
like I said I thought
I know the seven moves of jujitsu so I'm
good and I wasn't another platoon and so
I'm just like okay cool I know did you
in my mind I actually thought I knew
jujitsu like I'm good
I know I know everything you know look
it's like I know the alphabet right I
know these words so I'm good and then
but you kept training at what point did
you find Fabio alright so it had been I
was getting out at that time okay so we
do we both do another platoon right I'm
in an art platoon so I'm on a ship you
go back on a SpecOps deployment to Guam
did you go to Guam so you go to Guam and
you're training that whole time yes and
then you come home continue the training
yeah and at that point I was like hey
you know do they have like any kind of
you know like any other places I can
train you know I want to learn more and
I'm thinking about you know getting out
and he's like well you know Steve was
like you know we should um maybe check
out a tournament and I'm like all right
yeah okay and I was the same way and I'm
thinking you know at this point you know
I know jiu-jitsu and he wrote a letter
to me he wrote a letter and sealed it
and he said when you get up there at the
tournament give this letter to hoist and
I went up there and um I met hoist and
gave him the letter he opened it and he
said well you've been training with
Steve for two years you're a blue belt
now and so I got my blue belt from Royce
Gracie has never had trained with him at
all but got my blue belt there to do the
tournament because like two years you
know go in the blue belt division but I
had never trained with the key like when
I got there I was like you know everyone
had diesel and I was like we'd always
done nogi mm-hmm and my first opponent
was Craig Cole Fabio's first black dog
on hearing and I think it was maybe the
worst I might have been a record for the
worst loss in jujitsu because
I didn't get tapped out but it was like
I just never been swept that many times
because he had the key and I'd never
seen those sweeps because I was always
going noogie and and it was like
literally like 30 nothing like just I
was just getting thrown around and then
I remember back then like my defense
forearm lock when the someone gets mad
it was to put your arm up and when they
go for it yank your own without as fast
as possible and he almost caught me with
the arm up but when I'm trying to get my
arm out and then all of the friends are
on the side like yelling break it and
it's called jiu-jitsu and yeah it was
probably including Fabio if he was there
on the side Fabio was reffing
Oh Jack that's gonna work out good so
then after that you know I was like hey
you know is there that I came Fabio
Santos is opening a school down in San
Diego and that's where you've been
trained if you want to go down and train
under our system so I was like yeah you
know I would definitely explore it and
you know when I went back I told Steve
would happen and he was like you know
well you know expand your horizons learn
as much as you can and so I started with
Fabio and I were trained at Steve's and
then at a certain point I'd um I'd
gotten out at this point and I'm now
getting ready to go on to school so I
had the GI Bill and I'm I started
working at Mesa College like it's local
junior college was it like 1995 yes and
so 90 I started at Fabio's in 95 during
the spring time okay it sounds like very
very early at Fabio's like those those
are some good times - yeah and then and
then when you got out what was your plan
when you got out I didn't really have a
plan you know I was just like um I mean
you realize coming from where I were I
did I haven't really seen much I mean
I've been in the teams by me like
haven't you in like I didn't even go to
school or anything after I went in right
after high school
so I was like really curious about just
exploring so it's like go to school I'm
gonna try anything I can you know just
looking at the world seeing what
everything is about
you know I think people who do come from
areas like the projects in a sense
you're kind of sequestered and you're
not maybe seeing the big picture of
things and I will say that's something
for everyone you know you're you're in
your environment and no one ever sees
the whole picture maybe we see most of
the pictures but not the whole thing and
so I think at that point I wanted to
just kind of explore life and that my
plan was if I don't like it I can go
back in see lips so so then how many how
many hours a day were you trained in
jiu-jitsu when you got out well what I
did was I wanted a way to be able to
train a lot so I ended up working at
Fabio's essentially you know like
cleaning the match doing the intro class
running the students around you know the
morning and the night class so it's just
there are all the open hours a month my
roommate John and we basically were like
Fabio's assistants the road right now at
some point I guess it was in late 95 or
early 96 you came to my house you came
to my house and said hey bro you wanna
you wanna go train and I was like yeah I
was like of course so we go across the
street to the girl to the to the park
across the street from my house in
Coronado from my apartment in Coronado
we go down there and do you just you
just you know you're like let's roll and
so you know I attacked you or whatever
and you were just triangle armlock you
know whatever choke back you just
annihilated annihilated me and it's
actually it's crazy right it's like
you had gotten so good and I just
remember saying alright give me the
address this place I'll be down there is
it open today because I'll go down there
today if it's open today and if it's not
open today then I'll be down there
tomorrow and I went down there and I
said I remember talking to Fabio's wife
and I said oh yeah I'm here I want to
sign up for unlimited classes and she's
like well do you want to try it first
and like no I just want to sign up for
unlimited classes and she's like okay so
that was that and then we then it was on
with the old school the old school route
at Fabio's which was a beast crew yeah
you Dean Lister
Craig call Craig call James Nielson
right some beasts in there Greg Mac
ended up showing up along the way along
the way who else dr. Mick Brent was
there too
brent was there remember Kim yeah I see
Kim at wrestling tournaments sometimes
he's a referee at risk wrestling
tournaments Louie Lewis Lewis Lewis the
Korean dude from Oh Lewis yeah yeah he
was we use it because he was a judo guy
originally but he used to go hard yeah
especially like early when he showed up
he would he would go hard he was there
to use there to win everyone it's you
know I look at that now in hindsight you
know having have some had some judo
experience as well judo the the the way
people attack is I would say they're
trying to make you tap they're they're
not looking for you to tap like you know
I've I've even traveled in certain areas
in Asia you can no one taps to chokes
it's just all you caught me in a choke
I'm going out there just not going to
tap to a choke so I think the judo guys
anyone who's a judoka when they get they
go for their taps like if you stand up
in the guard and the guy has your arm
they're gonna try to break it so that if
the fight does continue now you have one
arm mm-hmm so if you don't tap they're
still going to win because you have one
or
at what point and I think Fabio used to
say this he used to say you're the only
person Jeff that went from jiu-jitsu to
capoeira what when did you start getting
into capoeira
oh that was like maybe a year after I
got out and essentially it's just like
I've been saying I want to explore and
try different things you know I've never
been the type of person that okay don't
do this I'm like well why not you know
so I was experimenting and I was like
it's a good way to get good condition
for jiu-jitsu you know one learn
something different and that that's
another thing I remember is when you
came to my house to fight me I was like
what how would you uh you know if you if
we were gonna fight how would you what
would you do like how would you start it
and you did some weird kappa Wetty stuff
yeah I started doing comfortable yeah
and I was all confused and I'm like oh
man I don't even know what's happening
this is horrible and then I'm in a
triangle tapping out and we were
competing a lot back then like every
opportunity we would get we would go and
compete and one of the most well it
might be it's definitely the top
probably five that I've been at live
matches was we were at neutral grounds
oh yeah which was in the ghetto and in
like Inglewood or something I mean it is
a nasty part of LA and it was uh it was
like in the backyard of some crappy you
know house and they had a cage there and
there's freaking rabid pit bulls in the
alley and everything and we roll in
there and I like we all had matches and
they set up it wasn't a tournament was
just like one match and God think about
those matches there was so you had a
well Dean had a match against the the
Armenian dude that was like a grown man
and he I thought Dean I thought he like
I thought the guy died of exhaustion or
something in the ring I don't know if
you remember that one it was mayhem and
Armenian guys are cranking the Armenian
music on boom bah
season stuff it was it was so crazy
there was not dude and the cool thing is
that's like the Karo Parisyan crew like
that's them so like when Carl Parisian
was like oh yeah dude
it was one of like the old-school guys
they had that that in they were all kind
of linked to judo gene LeBell so it was
just like really cool to be a part of
that but you had a match at neutral
grounds perfect in the two against a bow
Hershberger who was this he was he was
like Hickson's as far as I know he was
kind of Hickson's premier purple belt at
the time and at this time like purple
belt was kind of yeah if you were like
purple belt was the highest level that
Americans had at this point right and so
you had this match against um against
that guy and he was a great guy I mean
he's a great competitor he competed all
time we team all time but you but he was
a lot bigger than you a lot bigger than
you you know he was probably like what
do you think 200 220 or something like
that big guy and you guys threw down you
know jiu-jitsu match and you know he was
kind of on top and kind of as far as I
can remember sort of dominating the
match and then there came the triangle
out of nowhere and that was kind of nuts
man
you won that is their video that
anywhere oh no video have them maybe a
couple of pictures of it you know what
competition you know I look at the
competitions are I think it's really
good to test your skill against other
people in competition basically you're
looking at someone who has the same
skill level but you don't know their
game mm-hmm and it's up to you to try to
negotiate and you and have your
jiu-jitsu when the situation so I you
know the tournaments are good I think
but um you know I've because of Steve
because of where I grew up my focus as
far as your q is self-defense
that's my main focus you know I look at
the matches like this person won today
but then if they repeat the match what
happens then and repeated again and
again and again that's how you find out
who's there who's the best you found out
who's the best right there you know so I
I kind of I want to keep my you know my
humility I guess I would say as far as
like fighting is concerned anyone can
lose at any time so you know make sure
your techniques on point and be aware
yeah that's a weird thing to is it's
it's a cool thing about jujitsu it's
like you can go so hard you can go as
hard as you can you know like that's the
way Jitsu works but then there's the
other thing is it's as close as it is to
a fight it's not even a real fight it's
still not a real fight and well then
what do you have in those other arenas
what can you do what can you
how can you what can you create really
is what it boils down to there's a
creativity aspect that's another thing
that you kind of excel at with jujitsu
is there's the creative aspect of kind
of creating moves and creating series
that work really well together how much
how much you went to like I remember you
know when I would see you cuz because
eventually you know we weren't all
training at fabio's anymore and we were
training at different places and so when
I see you it always be like you'd be
deep into yoga you'd be deep into
kettlebells or you'd be deep in a
Bulgarian bag or you'd be deep into
Sambo you were always going down these
different paths to add to your to add to
your repertoire of moves and movement
and strength and conditioning yes
is that just still something that you're
always doing yes I mean one thing that
happened a very pivotal thing you know
when I was in school the thing I focused
on first was trying to get some type of
work so they had the San Diego Community
College fitness specialists I've they
had that the first year I was in that
first class and so I did that to become
a personal trainer the way personal
training set up you know if you work for
like an organization like ace or
something like that you always have to
upgrade your your training
and so what I did was album I would go
outside of a sand sea oh you know what's
this like what's this like and I saw
this advertisement for circular strength
training and I went to Bellingham
Washington and I did the CST course with
Scott Sonnen and you know how it's why
is that relevant to what we're talking
about
Scott Sonnen is the guy who kind of
coined the term the saddle and he's a
Samba instructor distinguished master of
sport American and he basically
developed that leg lock game of the
saddle which everyone does today
especially you know if you're in nogi
that's a big part of the jiu jitsu I
don't think he gets the credit for it
but he even had a video that came out
that didn't really go over to I guess
like as far as like it is everyone knows
it now mm-hmm but he doesn't get the
credit for it so I am I did want to
mention that I trained with him with the
clubs and did that certification but
then afterwards we went and trained
together and you know I learned some
things about the basically the thing I
learned is no martial art has all the
answers and if you understand the
counters to a martial art you can
counter it if you are on time and you do
the technique right and you know from
his end Sambo judo I think he did a
Systema as well I don't really know too
much about that but I was concerned with
learning Sambo and he was like hey you
know you can even if you like compete in
Samba but you're gonna have to get your
throws together cuz I was just purely
jujitsu and I was like all right yeah
we'll want to get back home I'll do some
judo I'm like yeah I'll do some judo for
like two weeks and then I'll be ready
for Samba and I've gotten to judo and I
learned
and judo is its own thing mm-hmm
and so I never really I never really had
much contact with Scotts on and after
that but you know he foreign for him I
probably have never done judo so then I
started training at judo America and
continued on in judo so I think it's
very important if you are a true Jitsu
cut you definitely need to learn some
type of stand up fighting whether it's
striking or throwing wrestling learn
something that you can do stand up
because if you cannot get the takedown
were you gonna do block punches with
your face so you don't want to do that
and so where's it all lead to where does
it lead to you what are you doing now
well I was uh teaching jiu-jitsu at
Studio 540 and doing a lot of privates
personal training it's people probably
know right now studio 540 is defunct but
I'm still continuing on with personal
training and jiu-jitsu privates and also
I travel so at a certain point you know
mark mm-hmm we uh another mutual friend
that started with us in jujitsu another
team guy he had a school in Coronado and
invited me to come you know train there
and teach there so I started doing that
and a Russian guy came in a judoka and
he was curious about jiu-jitsu and
started training with us and then he
said hey you know we need to see we want
to see some jiu-jitsu in Russia and he
said hey if one of you guys want to come
out you know come on out and teach me
and I'll set everything up and there
were no takers I was like yeah well I'm
not doing anything I'll go and so I
ended up going to Vladivostok and so
I've been going there like you know once
a year every two years and work with
those guys um I had a guy that I uh that
I worked with in Germany
Ramar he owns a tensho it's a really
great school in Hamburg Germany so
usually on this trip I'll go to Russia
Vladivostok fly away across to Moscow
and then over to Humber of Germany train
with those guys then I stopped over in
New York visit my brother and then all
the way back here where you have you
learned a new Russian in every country
I've been and everyone speaking English
I'm really had home incentive to really
learn much how long do you usually stay
in Russia for usually two weeks so your
true your training in Russia with mostly
judo based no guys ditch Sambo guys just
fighters nice lot Vladivostok team
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu guys yeah okay yeah
I mean jiu-jitsu is a worldwide martial
art right now that's everywhere
well I guess I thought that cuz you said
when the guy came to your school he was
a judo guy yeah he was at judo guy and
and basically in the judo world all this
and you know that jiu-jitsu guy you know
they're they're learning like if you go
on the ground you're probably gonna get
tapped out and so he wanted to learn
something a bit about BJJ and so now one
oh and and the issue there is their
training with dole instructor mm-hmm
they're just going off video and there
are some hardcore highly skilled guys
over there and and women I mean like
this it's uh I mean in this area where
we're training before class they have a
Samba and they have judo men's and
women's you know and and everyone's
going hard so I mean I think everyone
needs to especially here Brazil get
ready because in Russia they're like
they're doing I think that it's Russian
Federation on Brazilian jiu-jitsu
but they allow all the leglocks hmm so
you have guys who are highly skilled at
Samba learning and and if you're a
highly skilled at Samba if you're a
master spore in Samba you're probably a
master sport in judo or at least a black
belt because the styles are very very
similar except it's you know Sam of
course has the leg locks so you better
be prepared because I think you know
over time they're used to something that
you're not used to and it can make a
difference when you say they're used to
something I'm saying like do Aggie
tournament and all leg locks are allowed
or got it got it yeah in ten years
what's gonna happen yeah when those guys
can pee here yeah and they're gonna have
to at some point in America open up leg
locks for the game it's just it's silly
right
well the issue is it's a sport and
they're looking at you know long-term
health of people and I can tell you when
I'm in a Samba class like looking at the
Samba fighters in Russia I think
everyone has at least one leg rat yeah
don't you think it's a little bit too
like the culture over there is a little
bit different just in terms of like yeah
Russian culture is very different
why cuz they're getting nuts more often
like the guys relay but like you say you
see everyone with a leg wrap meaning
they kind of maybe have an injury or
hurt legs yes
leg locks and stuff yeah that's what I
was thinking - I was like wait but like
we have like no ghee has leg locks here
yeah so we don't have that much of that
but then how you say like Russian they
go hard
so consider leg locks is being a
complete part of the the jiu-jitsu
culture or Sambo and all this but they
go hard yeah that's when you're gonna
see that yeah and and also what is
complete I mean if you look at you know
having um trained in judo Nell your con
owes original vision was you have a
style where you can strike you can throw
oh you're still moving on the ground I
can submit so it's I think it's in Paris
whether you learn wrestling judo samba
you need some type of stand-up art mmm
you know that's the full complete system
yeah it's tough to uh like the kids that
wrestle like you like if you if you
start jiu-jitsu I'm not saying you're
not gonna be able to pull this off but
if you start jiu-jitsu at whatever you
know 24 or 31 or whatever you start
later in life to get the reps in for the
takedown game when you're a little bit
more fragile and compared to a kid that
wrestled you know six years old eight
years old ten years old through high
school had you know hundreds of
tournaments hundreds of hours in the on
the mat doing takedowns and by the time
like that's why the UFC is so dominated
by wrestlers because they are they have
that in thing just embedded they don't
they don't need to learn that that's
embedded in them they know how to get
that takedown they know how to get out
takedown they know how to scramble
there's a huge part of that that
wrestling comes in and that's what's
when you start taking that and you just
make replace wrestling with Sambo and
now you've been doing that your whole
life which has takedowns yes it also has
submissions it also has knee locks and
fault locks I wish that there was just
something like unified grappling that's
that's a vision you know that was kind
of happening at studio 540 yeah all
different kinds of black belts from all
over coming together to teach their
jujitsu I mean because but beyond that
right
what you need is unified grappling where
the whole world says these are the rules
like these are the rules the whole world
so wet in the Olympics there's no more
judo wrestling at freestyle wrestling
Grieco it's just like grappling unified
grappling if you were if you want a like
if we're gonna get invaded by aliens
that grapple if we're gonna compete with
them we got a unified we gotta unify
this pretty quickly otherwise they're
gonna have a leg up because they've been
out there you know in there
planet sir and there they've combined it
all together
they got a unified grappling potentially
this is what are we gonna tell the
aliens Jeff hey no no reaping here hey
no what is it no guillotines you know no
guillotines from that position we can't
tell that to an alien they don't care
there's they're there to win that's very
true
unified grappling free the world you
know on that subject
this might rub a few people the wrong
way but I think when I look at you Jitsu
one thing I think that can really help
is to make a rule set of that switched
like in other words if I pass your guard
that's three points make that an
advantage and make actual submissions
like if you have to escape it those are
the points we what finishes fights where
you could actually have killed this
person
chokes make those four points and if I
see I have the choke on and you're
trying to escape and you get out as four
points and then this way people are
going after submissions more rather than
because I had a judoka judoka buddy Ross
and he would do jujitsu tournaments in
the black belt division
he's a judo black belt and he would win
some of these tournaments
you know 5050 I would assume but
basically he's like I'm gonna throw and
stay on top and stay out of submissions
and basically he could do that at will
cuz he's like a legit judoka and that's
that's a problem realized you do it this
way that's just an advantage but you now
you're forcing people to go for the
submission more yeah well maybe that's
part of the unified grappling rules is
chokes four points arm locks shoulder
locks type stuff maybe three points BJJ
doesn't like leg locks too much make
that two points here's the only here's
the only argument I'll say against that
if you're in a fight and you get across
side you get past someone's guard that's
a real problem
like if we if we go to a real fight
that's why I think it's so advantageous
well that's why I think it's a big deal
because they say oh if you pass the
guard if we you want a fight you're got
a you're in a much much much worse
situation than you were in a second ago
right so that's and if you're mounted
even worse right half guard a little bit
but so I think there's there Elian if
you give up the back obviously in a real
fight that's the that's the biggest
problem
so you remove the striking but if you
added the striking in those positions
are in some ways even more important
even more relevant so I'm not leaning
philosophy I didn't say the relevance of
the of those positions or any less I'm
just saying for a sport to get people to
go more for submissions rather than cuz
they're a we've seen it mm-hmm
bunch of guys who wrestled in high
school I got to take down advantage I'll
take this person down wiggle a little
bit to make sure the ref thinks I'm
still doing something they stand us up
I'd do it again and they won and they
never submitted anyone yeah and you
attempted a submission yeah you feel
cheated you're on the bottom doing gar
the whole time and couldn't do anything
because you got stalled out yeah
installing is a real thing there you
can't if someone's stalling that's like
a hard thing to undo you know I mean
without strikes yeah yeah and then you
had the strikes in yeah that's a whole
different thing so you're talking about
essentially like with the philosophy you
know of fighting yeah you know it's kind
of key to that but for the sport you're
you're absolutely right like even if
like even just stalling in general like
even if you're just up by some points
that you got from all your cool
takedowns or whatever and then they take
you down and you're now they're only
kind of they're only the only thing they
can do really is tap you out because
there's maybe a minute left they can't
score 14 points in a minute to not get
tapped out if someone's just my whole
thing yeah your mouth you just like the
draw and you just don't want to get get
tapped out that's hard for the guy it's
hard to tap someone out like way harder
to tap someone out when they're their
whole thing is just not to get tapped
out so yeah it can be like an issue
for the sport I think what philosophy do
you follow you know you still get the
same result of guard passing in
positional dominance because well what
kind of arm walks are you doing when
you're in someone's guard there you know
I'm not gonna do a Kimura to you if I'm
in your guard since you still forced to
I mean those principles of also Comey
those are all positions right of pinning
someone those are still gonna be
important I mean in judo
there's no there are no points for guard
passing it's just pin this person I know
if I have you pinned if I want to I
could bash you or I could go into
submissions right yeah so that the
advantage for guard passing or whatever
isn't the points it's because you're now
you're cross-eyed there's your advantage
so it's it's sort of like so use it then
yeah it's not such a great you know use
it but you're not giving points for that
getting stuff over here
that's the Jeff Higgs way yeah and I'm
not change you know I'm you know it's
just the thought you know maybe it's
nothing thought but the idea is to keep
the purity of going for submissions in
jujitsu I mean I think with rules that
we're seeing in BJJ judo is even worse
because it had a longer history of
taking dangerous moves out mm-hmm and
that's what I see happening in BJJ yeah
well I think the ultimate role set for
grappling is no striking that that's it
no time limit no submissions are barred
just you're not allowed to punch or
strike the other person or kick them
other than that you can get after it and
you can go as long as it takes
which means people are gonna have to you
know get up yeah yeah come on let's face
it I mean the sport thing you know you
can't make the audience know you know
five well I don't know if I'm somebody
smart people do to other sports that
take a really long time and they've
managed to televise that baseball game
takes many hours to write so you would
occasionally you'd get some weird match
that goes like nine hours before someone
taps out from dehydration that's what I
want to see I want to see someone tap
out for dehydration
you know what I'm saying cuz you're not
allowed to get a drink you got to go in
hydrated you got to go into fuel in your
system yeah so yeah it's not that
different I think than baseball but yeah
because baseball you have like
understood little breaks that's why we
can hang out right that's why it can
last so long
yeah edge it sued on no time limit
jiu-jitsu tournament there would be like
a limitation just by Nature yeah just by
the limitations of humans for the
audience remember then I'm gonna be
happy about that because at any moment
the match could technically turn around
for that for one of them I so know that
as you run three matches at the same
time so two of those matches are gonna
at least one of those out of three is
gonna be kind of exciting at some point
so just running three matches you focus
the television over there I got this
solved what did I have name for this
what was I naming it you know no unified
grappling yeah but there's just like no
no time limit death matches basically
because it's the only way there's one
way to win cool make the other person
tap out yeah that's the one way you win
yeah that's a game changer yeah remember
the Hickson tournaments that were like
that it was you but you could also win
by 15 points yeah so those those those
matches would not go along hmm those
matches would not go long you could win
by 15 points or submission
and those matches would be like seven
minutes four minutes 10 minutes
occasionally there'd be some you know 20
minute match yeah rarely but the Gracie
tournament is similar I mean they they
give you points for guard pass mount and
back control those are the only points
and you know the rest is continued until
someone gets submitted or or 15 points
yeah because 15 points does show you win
and if you beat somebody by 15 points
that means positionally if you were in a
real fight you would if you destroy them
yeah it's horrible when you get somebody
that's really good like positioning like
an MMA fighter to roll with and in like
I'll do this with Taylor we got a guy
here named Taylor Johnson he needs to
savage wrestler and he savage and
everything but you know he gets a
position on me and I'm just thinking if
he if we were in a fight right now
he would just he would be just killing
me he would be punching me in the head
until I was dead repeatedly like
repeatedly dead
so yeah if anybody wants to get ahold of
you like anyone who wants to get a
seminar because that's another thing you
know you mentioned it self-defense and
how that's kind of what your focus is
it's really solid like you have your own
little techniques in there you got moves
I know you do
weapons stuff if somebody wants to get
ahold of you to get some kind of
training what do they do who do they
contact I guess they could contact me
well how would they do that so this is
an issue Jocko sent me a text last night
and said do you have Instagram and I
said no I don't have any social media
mm-hmm and basically I can give you my
email you can call me and leave a
message do you have like an email that
could be open to the public because you
don't wanna be giving out your email
that's you know you're you're doing your
normal personal business on to a bunch
of people all right well let me let me
let me make one right now and then I'll
set this email up all right so we will
put that out in the future
yeah and I'll post it how to get in
touch with Jeff Beck or you got anything
else no that's it it's good good to see
you again yeah and then great to be here
thanks for me on yeah man any other any
other closing thoughts anything I missed
well I think right now it's a really
important thing we're looking at the
talking about the world situation right
now and
I think it's really important you know
with all these things going on that we
somehow get some cohesion because I mean
looking at jujitsu SEAL team all these
different ways of destruction it's a lot
easier to destroy than it is to create
and you know as we have to start
thinking on a species level I don't
really want to get preachy on people but
I mean just something I see if we don't
do it humans in general are getting so
good at war and destruction that we're
gonna end up killing ourselves and
really all around us you know you have
the universe we there's a wake-up call
now the whole planet got caught off
guard with the virus luckily I mean
there are a lot of people have died from
it but um the death rate is not like 50%
or higher I mean what if Ebola was as
contagious as this virus so we have to
be smart with what we're doing
basically nature given us human species
a wake-up call on got to start being
aware of what's going on outside of our
little bubble the human bubble that's uh
basically what I wanted to say there's
like a um this is you know physicist you
familiar with all the Kardashev scale no
so a physicist was um astronomer looking
out into space you know with his
equipment and what do you look for in
space for life and so he started coming
up with things that he would look up
look for and he came up with these
levels type 0 type 1 type 2 type 3 and
humans right now we're a type 0
civilization civilization right type 1
is when we actually have
a really good control of the planetary
systems and then type 2 is one we have
control of the energy of the Sun and
type 3 the galaxy you know this is all
hypothetical but the issue is you know
with our capability at war right now
we've got to be really careful because
if we don't reach that type one level
where you know at a certain point we're
going to be able to give there's going
to be food everything for everyone
you see I'm saying like over time humans
make things easier mm-hmm and one of the
one of the issues we have is all
resources and stuff like that that are
if they're in low supply here you have
that starts causing skirmishes and stuff
like that so what I'm saying is over
time those problems are gonna be solved
but before we reach type 1 a certain
point weapons and and how to fight that
also starts to spread and then at a
certain point we can end up destroying
ourselves before we even reach type one
civilization and type one type one
allows us to leave the planet I just
yeah of course we'll be at a point where
uh you know we're not even type one now
and we've left the planet leave the
planet and stay somewhere note everyone
has harness the energy of our planet
like all the energy not just like oil or
whatever it's like basically utilize
100% of the energy available from our
planet whatever that is that's type-0
type-1 that's type one we're not even
there yet on this thing how do you know
the second I was gonna say you just
figured it out are we eating you know we
hang out at the same spots you know so
essentially I'm getting at you know we
don't want to get caught off guard and I
see there's a lot of separation right
now and a lot of social unrest we have
to get through that to a point where we
start to unify it's very very tough to
do but hopefully it can happen what do
you see as like when you see
the the dis unification like what do you
see as things to move in the right
direction of becoming unified again well
I think one of the main reasons is not
thinking on a species level and you know
when I'm talking about this I feel kind
of funny because it feels like I'm
talking in the clouds or something like
that but I'm just being really genuine
and sincere about the human species
looking at itself as a species and not
as so separate you know in my travels
I've been came from the projects came
out to came here and became a seal in uh
San Diego my travels in jujitsu learning
their judo traveling around the world
I've seen all kinds of different people
you know in SEAL team Southeast Asia
bent down Central America South America
Russia and I see everyone really wants
the same thing basics of life you know
and and if you if you're in the military
going to Russia it's kind of a big deal
in the sense because they were like the
great enemy and I see like a family's
over there just like everybody else
everyone's trying to live their life the
best they can and the separatism that we
have is making a big problem we're gonna
end up killing ourselves before we reach
a level where everything can be better
for everyone that way I mean before I
even continues that sound like kind of
wacky no no you know what it is actually
like you make a good point where I say
and people got to point this out like
people like that's I mean that that's
obviously like good that you say that
people do say that everyone's worn out
but that's not a lot of time not what
you hear so when like what you're
talking about is essentially like you
know how if you have you know you have
kids all right where let's say you know
I don't know you have a goal to get
somewhere to do something or really just
a general goal as a family where it's
like okay our job as parents is to
maintain this household make sure you
guys are prepared for life when you grow
up and when you do that you're gonna be
successful in whatever way you want to
be and then you can sort of do the same
and
around we go right same kind of a
perpetuate that species exactly right so
you know in a small smaller analogy is
like a family situation but currently in
our family the whole world we're kind of
infighting you know the brothers and
sisters will fighting and it'd be like
hey he took my thing no no he hit him he
pulled my hair so he goes well you pull
my hair back even harder oh and now
they're fighting and then you're like
hey don't yell and then the wife is like
hey don't yell at her like that you
didn't have to say you know so we're all
in fighting we're forgetting about like
we don't forget about I think we get
distracted by just a little micro
feeling or the the short-term things
that go on and we start to forget about
you know progress you know I mean I just
I don't want to come off sounding
high-minded or anything like that you
know I'm just looking at the world per
se what has just happened not just our
country but all over the world like this
virus has come out and everyone got
caught with their pants down what kind
of prep was made everywhere now what if
that virus was more deadly mm-hmm what
we have to be smart yeah what would that
would that unify the world against a
common enemy or would it separate the
world more and here's remember I had
sort of gotten named Peter Atia he's a
doctor and he was a doctor in a in the
trauma center an ER doctor in Baltimore
and so I forget the statistics he was
dealing with something like 18 puncture
wounds a day so that's shootings and
stabbings this is Baltimore you know one
of the worst crime rates in it's
actually one of the worst crime rates in
the world I don't know if you knew that
it's in the whole world it's one of the
worst crime rates so that's what he's
dealing with and what he said was when
you have a family come in that's gone
through this kind of trauma usually it's
the loss of someone because these
puncture wounds or you know stabbings or
not everyone's as hate to use the word
not everyone's as lucky as your brother
was taking a seven-inch knife to the
chest and surviving right most people
are gonna die from that and that's what
happens so what he said was
if the family is tight their tight-knit
family and they and this horrible event
occurs this pressure will make them even
tighter
however opposite is also true if there's
fractures in the family those fractures
under that pressure explode and it
destroys the families so I think what
you're seeing right now and what you're
talking about is let's face it in the
world as a species
there's fractures right there's
fractures with different countries
there's fractures with different
cultures and all of a sudden we just got
put under pressure by the disease and
what we're seeing now is we're starting
to see these fractures expand and what I
will from my perspective the thing that
we miss and I keep trying to say this in
different ways and maybe I mean I'll
keep trying to say it you know within
the military what you end up doing is
you end up dehumanizing the enemy and
it's kind of a goal right kind of a goal
to say you know what I'm gonna have to
go kill these people that's what I'm
gonna get told to do I'm gonna go kill
these people so you know what I'm not
even gonna call them people because
there's some part of your subconscious
that says hey it's not okay to kill
people so you know what I'm gonna call
them animals I'm gonna call them savages
I'm gonna call them whatever I'm gonna
call them Krauts right World War two I'm
gonna call them gooks in the Korean War
we're gonna give them names that's not
people so now we start to dehumanize
them and now officer it's a little
easier makes that job a little bit
easier to kill them okay so that's war
that's what happens there well what
happens when you start looking at of the
different culture and you start doing
the same thing because you're like well
I got to take care of the P we're gonna
we're getting pressured by this disease
we're getting pressured by it and I'm
gonna take care of the people are with
me and what do i do how do i how do I be
mentally okay with that I got a good
solution for you I'm gonna dehumanize
the other people and now we get
separated and now we don't talk to them
and so that's why when you talk about
Jeff when you go
these other countries and you start
talking to people all of a sudden
they're not Russians to you they're
whatever
Ivan you know who they're a person with
a family and it becomes they become
humanized to you just like when they
meet you and they go you know they have
this horrible vision of what Americans
are like and then they meet you and
you're cool
and guess what you all do jujitsu and
you like foot locks and it's like all of
a sudden it becomes human but we don't
do that we don't humanize each other on
a broad scale which is very strange
right now because we should have the
ability to do that better than anyone
right now right because we've got all
these communication systems set up where
we should be able to say hey everybody
look let's let's be together
but instead we show each other the worst
part of our of ourselves and and we
place blame instead of taking ownership
and that's kind of how we do so instead
of us unifying as you said Jeff this
pressure that gets put on us by
something like this virus all of a
sudden we become more fragmented and
when we come fragmented the ability to
communicate with each other goes down
instead of up and the possibility of
someone actually saying hey hold on a
minute you know other human or other
thing wait maybe you have some of the
same whatever you just said Jeff about
like hey everyone's pretty much got the
same goals right like you said like hey
I want my kids to have a better life
than me
I want my kids to do better than me I
want them to have a nice be able to be
able to have their own family and kind
of repeat what we did here that's kind
of a common theme and it's the same
thing in Iraq you know whenever I
explain on Iraqi family to people I say
oh if you want to know what an Iraqi
families like it's very easy for me to
explain it's like an American family
like if you have you asking some Iraqi
dad what his goal is his goal is to take
care of his kids you know build up a
house build the business or their kid
that's what their goals are the same
thing when you ask an American dad that
same thing so it's across the board
we get in these situations where instead
of where we're all like a mass
dehumanization mode
well Howard
the relevance to jujitsu is there is
definitely a clannish aspect to all
martial arts a trained Taekwondo your
training boy died you know you're
nothing you know this kind of attitude
of well and from my experience going and
learning a different martial art
starting from ground up you see that the
martial arts also all have the same goal
of I get into an altercation I can take
care of myself
you know so it's I think learning this
stuff has has kind of it's changed me in
a way where I'm trying to instead of
compare and contrast and trying to see
how we're more similar rather than how
we're more different that's a way the
way to say it yeah and the other
interesting thing about let's face it if
you if you know jujitsu more Thai boxing
wrestling Taekwondo ninjutsu can call
you if you know if you know 27 different
martial arts right and somebody
introduces you to the 29th if you have
an open mind you will learn something
yes from that other thing right it's
kind of like I mean back in the day Jeff
you and I lived through this where it
was a jujitsu move or it was bullshit if
it wasn't a bit if it wasn't a jujitsu
move like this is a jujitsu move then
it's bullshit
right that's that's the old mentality
like that is not a jujitsu move so
therefore it can't work and it shouldn't
be part of the system it shouldn't be
part of the world that's a bad attitude
to have and it's the same attitude if
you look at another culture and you're
like okay well there's a lot of things
that in that culture that is doesn't
make sense to me what does make sense
what how do you open your mind to say
okay well at least if I don't want to be
a part of that culture what can I take
from it what can I understand from it
how can I relate to it so it makes me
and my culture a little bit better
but more understanding have a better
grasp on the world and we we don't do
that just like the old-school martial
arts and specifically the old-school
jiu-jitsu was if it's not part of this
then it if it's not jiu-jitsu don't
don't do it doesn't work and it's don't
bring it in here and that's the way I
mean I think I guess you could say like
Bruce Lee you know he was kind of an
early adopter and you know if it doesn't
you know he had some great quotes of
which I can can't think of any right now
but it's some work what's useful discard
through there you go thank you absorb
what's useful discard the rest so that's
the attitude to have and yet what we
like to do in martial arts and in life
is discard everything else we're not
listening I don't want to know what you
know what you know doesn't make sense to
me and I don't want to be a part of it I
hope you know I'm not and I don't have
any misconceptions like you know we're
all gonna be holding hands singing
Kumbaya and all this stuff I'm not
saying anything well I don't want don't
hold hands with people but over
basically at what I'm saying is over
time what people have now they didn't
have a century ago you know humans
progress over time they get better all
people do this and the same thing with
you know our war and stuff like that we
got to find answers or we're gonna end
up destroying ourselves or in the fights
against ourselves something else gonna
get us and this is a warning sign from
nature you know there's a whole universe
out there I mean when you start studying
things in science like astronomy and
stuff like that and how really big and
expansive you know reality really is
we're in a really little small space now
I know maybe to some religious people
you know science perspective is not
really that great but um I'm trying to
deal with what we know with some
certainty you know what I do know
certainly is we're in this life right
now we want to make it the best we can
before it's over
and so that's that's why I was uh I
wanted to put that point out in an honor
on on a personal level like it seems
like you're doing your best to kind of
reach out the world and make that happen
through through jiu-jitsu through
martial arts yeah I I have to say even
SEAL team I mean getting in SEAL team
coming out of the projects I don't know
anyone from the projects this ended that
was in the teams during that time and
you know I was definitely unique in that
aspect so um you get introduced to all
different people and you know when you
travel around the world same thing and
are we going to keep doing what we're
doing because I think the path right now
might not be the best one and again with
humility because I know when you start
talking like this people are like you
know shut the hell up shut the fuck up
whatever this whatever the case when you
when you look at the is the the idea I
think I think here's here's the crazy
thing the most simplistic thing that
you've said is the thing that people
have such a hard time with which is
looking at all humans as one species
that's why when you put that video out
last week a couple we stand about
everyone being human I was like you know
that was a cool thing that you know it's
it's uh you know especially right now in
the state of the US what's going on you
know it's really important that we stay
smart you know because there is still
this virus out there that we have to be
aware of I was you know in my studies I
have a book here on pandemics mm-hmm
when you look at the 1918 pandemic you
had three waves some say maybe in a
fourth wave if you do the research but
the first way was regular flu that
started at
March 4th 1918 and then over the next
few months in the fall the virus mutated
and then kill upwards of 50 million
people that's a possibility
mm-hmm so we have to be smart with what
we're doing I understand the social
aspects that we're looking at - that's
important but um you know the health of
the planet - is also really important
gotta look out for each other
gotta look out for each other it's true
I think that's a good place to wrap this
up a little bit I have a question okay I
said you saw that video that chuckle
made a few weeks ago where'd you see
that video YouTube oh you sons call you
out or one of those guys you have social
media but you're always on private
you're that guy buddy I stand corrected
he's a darker yeah yeah okay I dig it I
dig it
what do you think you think you could
make an Instagram all right yeah or you
just have no interest in it whatsoever
that has been my main thought regarding
social media I mean like just the idea
of like let me take a picture and put it
online and show everybody what I'm doing
just I have no really um no affinity to
do that it's a I had a Facebook page I
started I actually opened it up and then
I never touched again I was having a
weird conversation with my two daughters
the other day sure and what they were
they were basically saying they don't
like Instagram because and and it's you
know how you hear people say like oh
it's comparative you know you compare
you enough comparing yourself with other
people and all in silence oh yeah you
know oh you compare with this you
compare with that you compare with
you're basically comparing your life
with the absolute best view that
everyone else has of their own life you
know that they're posing in front of the
Lambo or whatever in order to look cool
and and I gotta admit I don't really
think of that you don't I mean I don't
really think like I'm not really out
comparing and me probably because
like almost fifty years old and there's
an you know it's kind of like um it's an
old man that doesn't care anything but
you know when you're younger you're like
wait a second how is that person how's
that other person that's my age or a
little younger a little older how they
have this amazing situation going on and
I'm over here you know with not an
amazing situation yeah so I'm not
worried about you getting caught in that
trap jaw I think he'll be okay to
Instagram that's the one you just put up
yeah you take it you can put you put
words under it too you know
you can film videos the videos can be
ten minutes long there's something
called IG TV expert oh yeah so I'm
feeling like pretty sad right now
explain well the funny the really funny
thing is when I got on this path god I
hate even using that word I well I
started social media um Tim Ferriss when
I got done with interviewing with Tim
Ferriss he's like do you have do you
have social meeting like no he's like
you should get him like no and he goes
mm you really need to get it and I said
kind of like okay I mean he's a really
smart guy and does really well with what
he does I mean amazingly successful guy
and just cool before our work yes yeah
so he's telling me like you got a guy
that's done what Tim's done and I'm just
becoming a civilian kind of and he goes
yeah you need to get Twitter he goes
just get it and I said he said I'll show
you how to use it he never showed me
anything but the good thing is you know
what he knew that I didn't know is that
you there's nothing to show like this is
how you make it work you put up put
little words in here and and the thing
that you'll find interesting I guess if
it's using the right way I mean I've
made all kinds of incredible connections
through social media all kinds I mean I
would say 50% of the guests on this
podcast and I've had some amazing guests
were through social media they DM door
they emailed or they contact or whatever
and I'm talking I'm getting the World
War 2 veterans on here
and Vietnam that's I mean incredible
people that it's an honor to be able to
have them on here a lot of them come
from social media so I it's a great tool
it's a great way to communicate with
other people and just like everything
else in the world if you do it if you go
too far with it it can absolutely turn
it into a negative yes and there's some
pitfalls to like people will tell you
stuff on on social media that they would
never tell it to your face just every
day Oh smack talkers care what it yeah
exactly yeah so there's that if you go
in knowing that okay that's the thing
then yeah then you might not hit hit the
some of the people dude have you ever
had a hobby before yeah okay so let's
say your hobby is knitting right and you
get home and you're like okay I'm gonna
knit some yarns or whatever and that's
kind of your thing there are some people
there hobby what they do for fun is get
on social media and trying to basically
terrorize other people troll yeah
trolling I understand all of that stuff
you went up it's just like I've just
never felt like I want to do that really
let me take a picture of myself and then
post it for everybody in the world to
start looking at it just seems like a to
me yeah yeah in that way it is it is
what I see it's a change in society it
kind of almost takes away on anonymity
you are everyone's a star in a sense
yeah yeah but a lot of times like if you
have a business or something right and
you know how like you're like okay I
want to go to this I don't know chicken
restaurant or something or maybe even a
place where maybe the experience there
is more significant like um I don't you
a martial arts place or whatever and you
know you can go to Yelp or not an
old-school Google Yellow Pages whatever
and you don't have the number how we're
talking about yellow pages right now and
you know they're like okay well now I
got a drive down there too just to check
it out
I'm not even committed to you know so if
you have an Instagram for example um you
know you can see pictures of the place
you can see descriptions you can see
comments of people that you know may or
may not like it or whatever so you can
you know it is useful in a lot of
different ways other than everyone
trying to be a star even though I think
that's one of the more prevalent uses
for Instagram yeah by the way you know
waiters the whole thing is you don't
have to post a picture of yourself no
you can post a picture of a knife or a
picture of wall or a picture of a plant
or your line of a star or or sweaty
single single one or whatever you're
gonna do you're gonna do that so you
don't have to necessarily you know just
pose for pictures for yourself with your
shirt off or whatever yeah flexing you
know but yeah that's but you are right
though that is true but then again you
know what if you posted this one let's
say you're doing a seminar you post one
picture of the cool picture of the
seminar or whatever and then someone's
like hey you know your shoulders look
real solid you've been working on so the
next one you might be a little bit more
compelled to post a picture with me
maybe like in some good lighting or
something you know and then the comments
start rolling he seems that you see the
slippery slope though but this and
there's someone that says yeah but he's
got skinny wrists right and then all of
a sudden you're trying to have a wrist
workout oh yeah yeah me and then of
course that guy's now your enemy cuz
he's talking trash to you you know so
you're now you're back and forth with
him and now you gotta check to see what
your friend said about that guy saying
you know so it's a thing you know you
gotta watch out back in stone I think
you'll be all right bro yeah it's like
in a sense like a public record cuz at a
certain point right you're dead but the
3d stuff is still there it's like a
record maybe a hundred years from now
they're they can access who was this
person
what was this person like what are they
into it's like a historical account of
individuals yeah no doubt about it
voluntary yeah yeah I got some friends
that that have died and their social
media pages are there and I'm so happy
that their social media pages are there
cuz it's like yeah I can go on they're
still alive yeah still hang out a little
bit you know
so there's definitely a positive in that
regard yeah was that your question neck
on you remember what your question was
oh actually you know what my question
was key remember when you were doing the
eight pull-ups the pull-ups and you're
like I got the eight like almost got
what's the qualified thing for full UPS
how many of you have to get back then
was eight oh okay so you had to do 42
push-ups 50 sit-ups eight pull-ups then
you had to run a mile and a half in
Boots and long pants for I think 12
minutes and 30 seconds and then you had
to run you got do you swim using side
stroke or breaststroke 500 meters I
think in the same time like 12 minutes
and 30 seconds something like that and
this is all in one go or is it like day
one you do this like one after the other
swims usually first then calisthenics
stuff and then the run at the end got
you yeah those those let that level of
qualification is so not bad yeah yeah
like if you're a guy sitting there going
what I can do a pause yeah you're
totally wrong not totally wrong you're
gonna get destroyed if you take you 11
minutes and 30 seconds or whatever run
in a mile and a half and you think
you're gonna make it through buts you're
not even close yeah there I mean back in
the day and I'm surprised they haven't
changed it and they have changed it now
like once you're in the pipeline you
compete against everyone else so the way
it works now Jeff is what you get two
buds in order to go into a class they
give everyone in the class a screening a
physical screening test the top 165
people go if you don't make it you don't
go into class and if you don't make it I
think two times you're done so it's a
competition just to get into class see
who gets the best score so any pull-ups
ain't getting you nowhere is it like the
enhanced screening test cuz I remember
Ken the budge you got another screening
test when I in 74 where everything was
higher like 75 push-ups like 12 pull-ups
or something like that I just know it's
a competition so the max the minimum
fluctuates because if there's a bunch of
studs in your class and you're not going
to pull up
like oh yeah sorry you're not in class
yeah it's like later
the crazy thing is no matter what they
do to those standards the same know
where people quit but it's the weirdest
thing
it's definitely the cold the cold water
the cold water the lack of oxygen in the
sleep and the lack of sleep and then and
then those are that right there is 90%
of the quitters I think then you have
some people that you know whatever they
got some weird they'll get in their head
psychologically and they look man you
know you gotta recognize that they're
gonna try and make you quit yeah so if
they see some kind of weakness that they
see they can trip you up and they might
here's the thing you go up or you go
down you know they might be like hey no
one's gonna want to have you on this in
a platoon listen man you seem like a
good guy right little ego up whatever
you want opportunity if you got a team I
wouldn't want to work with you you don't
look like you can carry your weight and
like you're actually by staying here
yeah the rest your boat Pro crew you're
putting them at risk in the SEAL Teams
so even a good like if you're a
good-hearted person that has good intent
you want to take care your teammates the
best thing you can do to take care your
teammates right now is quick yeah Jim
you know mentally frustrated so they're
gonna figure out a common at you yeah
and when you're cold wet and tired yeah
that's the other thing you keep you know
people when you're cold wet and tired
man those scripts this option start
popping up in people's heads and they
start you know maybe they weren't
thinking about it but now they're
thinking well I really don't want to let
my teammates down and that hot coco
looks good over there I'm gonna go get
me some hot cocoa yes we had in our
flesh Swiss Miss hot cocoa and Krispy
Kreme Doughnuts oh that's an electric
blanket
sitting on the beach so you're sitting
in 58 degree water jackhammering
freezing cold and there's some quitter
up there with an electric blanket on and
a hot cup of cocoa they're calling you
out I laughed at that craziness it's so
you if that quits he doesn't just go
he doesn't just leave he's still there
they'd be very green make us they make a
positive spectacle out oh yeah well
here's the thing though and they treat
him like a bro - they don't they're not
harsh on okay they're not like they're
not like I'll get over your quitter
they're like it's okay yeah they're done
all psyops of everybody to me that's the
worst Martin there because if you're
just like oh yeah you're here's all the
quitters on display look at them
enjoying their hot cocoa it kind of
creates this divide like oh I don't want
to be that guy looks nice no I think
that guy's my husband actually you know
my yes okay yeah he made a decision yeah
you know this is probably a good
decision it's good decision for the
teams he really cares about the teams
because he doesn't want to bring the
teams down not look at you trying to
hurt the teams see I think I understand
you a little bit more now just a little
bit
I get it Jack all right so um I guess
we're all probably gonna start training
in jiu-jitsu if we're not already yes I
guess we're probably gonna be swinging
some kettlebells working out trying to
get better trying to humanize each other
yes we're just moving in a positive
direction yes sir what do you got for a
second Charles well we're gonna keep
ourselves in the game with what jaco
fuel supplements supplementation
important you know specially when your
body starts falling apart right okay
joint warfarin krill oil super krill oil
he tries to get a problem your joints go
out right you're gonna be thanking you
know what and you're taking the krill
oil and joint oh yeah no super grill
super killer yes sir cuz the krill oil
is made with a regular krill red natural
has not been screened supercro they made
it through the training yes sir and
they're ready to hook you up it makes
sense to don't get regular krill which
is also super Krell yes sir
also discipline both kinds of discipline
by the way the supplement discipline
okay for your brain or your body - but
you know all these things are gonna keep
you in the
big time jiu-jitsu or otherwise so Jeff
kovat before at the end of at the end of
January I went to Seattle New York San
Francisco Los Angeles Washington DC and
Austin Texas and in each one of those
locations as shook hands with one to two
thousand people and bro hugged fifty
percent of those people I did not get
covin matter of fact it never even liked
it never even got after my immune system
at all I got the test I'm not saying
that it's like this genetic thing but
it's now proven that if you're healthy
right if you workout yes if you eat
clean yes if you take vitamin D sure
also this will in back to the discipline
thing we do have cans of discipline RTD
cans stands for ready to drink in the
industry yes sir those are good those
are that I'd say actually in what I'm on
both
I'm be honest with you mmm the cans and
the powder yeah there's something really
good about just cracking open a cold
camp it's true and oh yeah Pete guys
thanks for the refrigerator by the way I
mean you know Joe's head is on it which
you know makes emotions about that whole
thing but overall good big hit at my
house Radley sent me this refrigerator
with Jacko's head face on the
refrigerator and very strange you want
to talk about strange tunnel Cove it's
strange right the world strange we got
strange people running for president
when your head starts showing up on your
friends refrigerators that's some
strange sighs that's some strange time
yes sir it is get some milk get some
protein in you proteins better than yeah
protein for protein which by the way the
have you tried the protein that make
Jeff because if you haven't tried it
it's 100 percent guaranteed to stop
Spanish flu it's guaranteed to stop
there this room it's the lab tested the
whole
you don't have to worry about it I'm one
of those what it was it made of well
this I don't know all the ingredients
but I will tell you this it's clean
protein in the form of a dessert that's
what I do know I don't know the
ingredients we're gonna have to contact
Brian what's made out of I'm one of
those wacky vegans okay yeah you're not
eating because no cuz it's got a Cassie
and it's got the milk protein in it Oh
Matt and egg protein so you're just out
across the board yeah you're gonna have
to uh well you're gonna have to eat
something else we inside unique Ovid I
want a can of that stuff oh yeah yeah
you'll go out and style also tea
chocolate tea yeah I want something a
little lighter that some that I like
that yeah and you know since you are a
vegan it's not only vegan but it's also
organic sort of certified organic you
see think I'm playing around over here I
got your back I got your back rigged I'm
I'm gonna stop you from catching Spanish
flu probably we prevent Kovan from
getting in your system and I'm gonna
protect your feegan rights right over
here yes is there such thing as vegan
rights
it's just regular rights right yeah yes
sir isn't the vegan rights a thing I'd
not that I know of but I don't know
maybe we could start a movement anyway
so these vegan rights a thing
not that I know okay oh man just like
there's no keto rights there's no other
dietary philosopher and arguments that
no vegan is a dietary change sorry and
it there's a philosophy behind it for
sure
oh yeah 100% I dig it too but oh I don't
think you can choose that kind of
philosophy and then gain sort of you
know more rights or lose right never
that matters oh boy I'm gonna start a
keto right movement all right well I'm
going to Paleo rates over here right on
straight up okay I got start paleo first
yeah anyway speaking of a thing Jiu
Jitsu right anyway everything we just
talked about you can all vote you can
get on Origin mancom or you can get it
at the Vitamin Shoppe yes sir the
vitamin shoppe be what was the first one
origin main calm origin main
yep main like the state mister domain
origin man because of your origins yes
also at origin mein kampf jiu-jitsu keys
and rash guards okay these keys and rash
guards are made 100 percent of America
100 percent even the cotton that they
grow to form the material even that
grown in America 100 percent 100 percent
it's a big deal so yeah when we go back
to jiu-jitsu we need a new key if you
don't have one already even if you do
have one grab an original yeah that's
why you know one thing about jiu-jitsu I
wanted to say to for all those people
who are like sweating the load about you
know I haven't trained in a while you
know I am had an injury from the
military that just got worse doing
jiu-jitsu my neck got hurt really badly
so I was supposed to get fusion on a c5
to c7 and I was out for two years
I just didn't train so when you come
back you know Jiu Jitsu is not going
away so when you come back you will get
better all those techniques you've been
working on that stuff's kind of just
just standing in your mind mixing and
matching and forming into new things
you'll be better once you get your
conditioning back yeah don't do not
sweat it like a lot of people like I'm
looking at these I haven't trained in a
while yet but the conditioning thing
that's gonna be a thing especially if
you like to go hard right you're gonna
jump back in there try to go hard in
Braille you're gonna yeah when you come
back come back smart just nice and slow
easy get it actually and I think it's
also while you're not rolling do your
conditioning yes no it is a lifestyle
you eat right train right you know you
got to have your conditioning going on
so you should be doing that in other
words stay on the path and also when you
come back you don't necessarily have to
ramp it up you could just go 17 rounds
deathmatches come and get it
anyway yeah so yeah I get or Jinky if
you love you know when you get back into
it if you haven't already got back yeah
yeah anyway a lot of stuff on there or
do you mean calm boots boots jeez oh
yeah t-shirts all ain't it all made in
America in the good old US of A it's
true also chuckles the store it's called
Jocko store merchandise super original
yeah creative whatever
but hey man it works jockle story easy
to remember that's where you can get
t-shirts discipline equals freedom you
know this one that I got on good you
know represent oh you know a lot of cool
stuff on this hand I got on yeah
def core all day to the core all day all
day yeah doctor so doc calm if you like
something a man get something also
subscribe to this podcast you can
scrapped her wherever you can leave a
review we will laugh at your review if
it's funny and if it's cool
yes and if it's not funny it's not clone
doesn't have any layers well we
appreciate it cool still what's so cool
would you uh like when you're looking at
comments and stuff you get a lot of do
you get some negative stuff like people
trying to fire it up on you for this
podcast yeah almost none
it's really cool everyone's super stoked
on it but yeah you know some people give
some feedback that might be considered
negative but I look at it with an open
mind and I say hmm maybe there's some
adjustments I could make maybe I could
do a better job we also got the thread
we're almost out with a new thread with
a new name and all that stuff I'll let
you know grounded podcast where we talk
about jiu-jitsu or your kid podcast
where we talk about being a warrior kid
don't forget if the warrior kids soap
including killer soap Irish oats Irish
Oaks ramped rinsed calm or on the jaw
closed or website you can get yourself
some soap so you and everyone that you
know get clean
so the byline is is uh what's this
called the the standard operating
procedure is I do a little bit of a
build-up and then I say stay clean and
you just took my byline yeah men so
normally I would say hey so everyone so
you everyone in you and your family can
stay clean and echo usually goes like
this
but can you you took the glory amen good
I like if you said that clean which is
also you know the precursor to stay in
Crete yes yes yes for those of us who
are not clearly quite yet going down
quick um so yeah we got a bunch of
podcasts we got a YouTube channel that
you can subscribe to if you want to see
echoes if you haven't seen this yet Jeff
echo puts ridiculously crazy amounts of
explosions and fire and Terminator heads
into his videos because he's all into
you know whatever that's called CGI well
I just watched uh terminated the other
day and that was what I studied in
school - what terminator video
terminated III Avenue true Media Arts
degree so my specialization was 3d
animation Oh both Maya and light wave
and digital video so video editing and
compositing and stuff he's kind of like
um you know the enlisted guy that
doesn't like the officers because they
think they know what they're talking
about because they went to college he
just he I felt it even exude that at all
like respect you know he's appear we're
peers in that way oh yeah we're peers
now that degree you have doesn't mean
anything apparently we're peers see how
I like the instigator
yes sir alright so we got a YouTube
channel we got psychological warfare
we got flip side canvas comm where you
can get visual representation of the
path got a bunch of books the code
leadership strategy and tactics way to
work at one two and three miking the
dragons discipline equals freedom Field
Manual extreme ownership for the
dichotomy leadership a salon front my
leadership consultancy EF online
komm if you want to talk to me and hang
out with me and hang out with everyone
on the Echelon front team go to EF
online.com and come and ask questions we
solve leadership's
leadership problems that's what we do
every day come and check it out we're on
there EF online comm the muster coming
up Phoenix Arizona September 16th and
17th in Dallas Texas December 3rd and
4th extreme ownership comm for details
we do we usually do an introduction of
jiu-jitsu at those things I'm not sure
what's gonna be happening because of the
current kovat environment cuz you know
what Jeff you know what we do we try and
be smart yeah so we're gonna try and be
smart and we may or may not do that
EF overwatch if you need people leaders
at your team go to EF overwatch comm
where we take leaders that understand
the principles that we talked about in
this podcast and they can take them and
bring them to your organization also
America America's mighty warriors dot
org
momily that's mark Lee's mom and she has
been on a mission on a mission since she
lost her son on a mission to help
service members their families gold star
families around the world if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
America's mighty warriors org and if you
haven't had enough of my plodding
platitudes or you need more of echos
misplaced mentions then you can find us
on the interwebs on Twitter Instagram
and on Facebook echoes out echo Charles
I am at Jocko willing Jeff is gonna make
some kind of social media of some kind
and we will tag him and he's gonna post
a picture of his face yeah if you want
to youtube if you want to see what Jeff
looks like on YouTube you can come on
here and check him out where you
probably already know what echo Charles
looks like and apparently echo Charles
does not look like he how he sounds you
know what's pretty funny about that I do
have a client that I do private with
and I don't think he's ever seen the
YouTube channel he just watches he just
listens to the podcast and he's like he
doesn't think he doesn't has no idea
what you look like and he's like he
thinks that I think he thinks you're
kind of a small guy yeah for sure
apparently EKKO Charles sounds like a
skinny white boy hipster hipster
hipsters often say like this yeah pretty
hip I guess but yeah that does not
surprise me I said no I should Craig man
this guy's pretty big guy yes we'll get
that we'll get your social media we'll
figure it out hopefully if not we'll get
you an email and if not we will find an
address that people can write you
letters - they're gonna mail Compubox
yeah and if not we can get smoke signals
going yeah
- Jeff fix Jeff you got any last words
yeah first and foremost uh thanks for
having me on I really appreciate it and
I do want to say thanks to a family
Fabio for showing me and jiu-jitsu
teaching me all my training partners and
Steve I will kind of leave that a little
bit anonymous there but big changed my
life from him and also James Harrison
who was uh my father's friend and really
kind of was a mentor to me and uh gave
me kind of still discipline me on what
it takes to overcome your life's
difficulties yeah that's awesome and you
know that that just you know it's a it's
a great reminder that when you're going
through life if you make a little effort
make a little effort to help somebody
out you know you can actually change the
trajectory of their entire life and we
all have people like that that did those
things along the way
and clearly that's a great example so
be cool to people help them out and with
that thanks Jeff
for for coming on thanks for your
service in the team obviously your
dedication to jiu-jitsu and thanks for
being my brother for the last thirty
years and like hopefully we can squeeze
out another thirty yeah I'm sure we will
but there's no guarantees as you once
said to me this is true time will tell
and to everyone else that has served or
is serving thank you for keeping the
world safe for freedom into the police
and law enforcement out there
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers Border Patrol
Secret Service thanks to all of you for
holding the line despite low pay and
high risk despite the lack of
appreciation that you receive know that
most of us are grateful for what you do
to keep us safe and everyone else out
there just remember that life is not
easy at all there's gonna be challenges
you're gonna get beat down there will be
punishment and you will fail sometimes
and that's okay that's okay as long as
you get back up and no matter what
remember what my brother Jeff Higgs says
simply do not quit and until next time
this is jeff higgs and echo and Jocko